I did not get filtered so hard from Bioshock. I needed a piss. I didn't want you guys to throw up.
I had to use the fucking screen because I went for a piss.
Hold on, what one's the game? Hi! Hi! This is Stronghold.
Don't wind me up. Hold on, wait, hold on. Oh shit, wait, no, I was going to do a meme.
Hold on, wait, forget I came on. Wait, forget I came on.
This guy isn't working. Fuck. It's supposed to be like this. Hold on.
I can't fucking see it.
Oh, there we go. There it is, there's the gag.
Hold on, hold on. That was the second part.
That's it, that's literally the gag. That's how much I try harder than that.
I went on Twitter really quickly and I was checking on the girl, seeing when they were up there because I was passed out.
And someone was like, play Halo. I'm like, play Halo without me str-
I think fuck not. So obviously I replied and then she DM'd me and she was like, you're the first person I thought of.
And I'm like, oh, I'm gonna fucking cry. I literally said in her message, I was like, I keep making everyone play fucking puzzle games with me
because we were originally going to play Portal 2 together but then it got delayed because of timing issues and all that.
And she's like, no, no, we'll still play Portal 2 and I'm like, oh god, I'm still making everyone play a random puzzle game. Fuck.
But yeah, there you go. That was funny.
I was mildly entertaining in my head. Wait, how have I got two of those?
Okay, and then I have a really funny marshmallow that made me hee-hee-ha. Oh, my fingers crashed.
Okay, this is, I'm so sorry to the person who sent this marshmallow. This made me laugh, okay?
More Halo while you are getting more Halo, unironically.
More Halo.
Hi, Brian. I actually heard you that time.
MNS188.
Thank you for the super chat. Yes, you're getting more Halo.
Uh, I just want to address this marshmallow which might be the most controversial thing I will ever address in my lifetime as Stony Cuddles.
Please, my good refling, my good sir.
I assure you, I am about one brain wrinkle away from being room temperature IQ.
It is not your fault if I misunderstand you.
I am not well-beared in these kinds of thing, of this thing called human interaction, okay?
Because I can't hear your voice either. I can't see where you're putting commas.
I can't see where you're putting tone behind things, okay?
So please do not worry if I misunderstand you.
I assure you, I am an absolute brainlet and the problem does not lie with you, okay?
Does that make sense?
Um, I know it makes you die a little.
Inside, I apologise. It's not, it's just, I'm not very smart. I really am not.
Um, I'm actually rather hearted.
Sometimes a wish is real, honestly.
What have I missed? We sung a little bit of Halo.
I swear you've got an amazing accent.
Thanks, I spawned in with it.
If you spawn in in Scotland too, you'll end up sounding like this.
Or if you move to Scotland, you might pick up the accent, although I don't know how true that is.
If later in life you move somewhere and they say, that marshmallow is my marshmallow.
That's a one minute ago. Well, I've caught you twice in the act.
Um, but I did, I did, I thought this one gave me a little tee-hee, a little eesh-hee-hee-hee.
Um, um, someone wants to just put, what, the back half of your hair into a ponytail.
Someone wants me to wear a ponytail.
Okay.
Is that because you want me to imply that I'm going to give you...
That thing?
We're already picking up your accent via osmosis.
From a high concentration gradient to a low concentration gradient through a something-something barrier.
I've completely forgotten.
Um, someone just says, have a nice afternoon.
We'll may love you so much. Love you too.
Okay, who's ready for some game crashing on Bioshock to me?
I'm ready.
I did not realise how quickly we were about to finish the game.
Turns out there's only three more missions left if you can consider me replaying Fontaine's location.
We're literally about to finish the game.
Um, she already got handlebars.
I can't wait for you to see my surprise because I got my surprise soon to aim.
I can rate this bake with no handlebars.
No handlebars.
Please don't look at my elbow. It's not attached.
The accent is spreading but Sunderers don't pick up on what blend it is.
Now I declare, what are you talking about?
I'm from Louisiana.
It's very hot right now.
Okay, now I'm going to open up the game because I've completely forgotten how on Earth I've opened this goddamn game.
I'm just going to go for it and pray that OBS picks up the game because I didn't change no sentence on it.
And then we'll make sure that the desktop is synchronised, synchronised to do.
Can you complete the game in eight hours?
I played like five hours of it.
I'm in Fontaine's lair.
Unfortunately, we did have a little oopsie-oopsie with a bug.
I was going to play it off but you guys wanted me to play it on so I'll play it on your face.
Why did I just get whispered to?
Oh my god, we have a...
I don't remember this. Am I going mental?
Oh, it's because it's their advertisement.
Australia? Fucking Australia, can't.
Sorry.
It also had a content creator reach out to me and she's like,
I'm like, I just added her right before the stream and I'm like, I'm so sorry, I'm about to stream,
but what are you some more hopeful you want to do if you have a preference?
And she's like, nah, no preference, just let the autism guide us.
And I'm like, fuck yeah, you're my kind of content creator.
If that's the way we communicate with one another,
we're like, yeah, just let the autism take the wheel.
What the fuck, that's so wildly inappropriate.
I love it here. I love it here.
I saw him saying, people, oh, v-tubers are so cat either through this or this or that.
No, motherfucker, you have to find the fucking gems.
And if the gems say, let the autism take the wheel,
you know you're in good hands with that person you're interacting with.
Get out.
And remember to spend your adamantium.
Okay.
Also, congrats if your name's Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Okay, great flings.
Oh, I didn't do all my announcements.
If you're a bleeding heart, you got two Patreon audio uploads, please do enjoy.
You also got a short upload where a zero was touching something,
very sus, but please enjoy.
If you are a hair member,
she's already done all her Patreon,
so there's not much of an update.
I'll just come out when it comes out.
It's already pre-listed in all that shit.
She also has a new short coming that is out,
and it's about her being a girl failure or something.
I don't know, v-tubers really like that terminology.
I think it's an insult, but that's just me.
You can watch it now.
It's literally on her YouTube channel if you're a hair member.
Yeah, yeah, check it out.
ASICAL also has a new short out.
Yes, I did a lot of work yesterday.
Can you tell that I'm proud of how much work I did?
ASICAL's Patreon Perfect Fine is already available.
She had a short come out,
and I've completely forgotten the nature of it.
Now, Emmy does have a short unlisted.
I've given her control when she wants to upload it,
because obviously Emmy now has access to at least uploading shorts again,
which is fine, which is good,
because she's got three really good ones on the way,
which I think you guys are going to love.
I've unlisted it.
It's up to her if she wants to put it out yet,
or if she'd rather do some sit-along with the algorithm
and wait for the one that I think is going to be popular.
It's up to her.
I'm not forcing anyone to do anything.
I just tag them and bag them.
I'm not even kidding.
I upload the shorts, and I schedule them,
and then I unlist them for those who would rather get a little bit late.
Emmy also got a Patreon-filled Patreon upload.
The audio...
I think it was the roommate body swap,
so she fucking shags it.
That's the newest Emmy audio.
Snippets!
Snippets, your lovely senpai,
did also get an upload of a short where she was feeding people like fucking seagulls.
She like mashed the crisps up in her hand and then offered it to them.
Azura's Patreon audios were giant tests.
I finally did it.
It's a giant test, right?
So, you're a regular schmugular size,
and you're dating a giant test,
but you're not really dating.
You're like a one night stand type thing,
but then the end of the plot implies you're going to do more.
So depending on how much praise it gets,
if it's a well-liked audio,
I'll give it a sequel.
It's not that well-liked.
I'll just leave it as it is, regular schmugular.
And then another one where you tie Azura up unbelievably.
How dare you?
As for Mercy, Snippets again have a further update for you.
The third editor is in play and has already edited the Mercy audio.
So I'm going to make a little handshake emote with the Snippets today.
My job, once I finished Bioshock 2 and had a little brain rot to myself,
I am going to subtitle the wazoo out of that YouTube roleplay for Mercy.
And then I'm going to upload it.
She also has a highlight of, I believe, Harvester is the game.
The highlight is unlisted.
It's not being published yet.
So either the highlight will come out or the ASMR will come out.
But I think the ASMR is probably going to come out.
I got caught up on a heck of a lot of work.
So please do enjoy any shorts you find,
any Patreon audios that may have came out.
As for Snow Berries and Pin Pals,
your two lovely Oshideces are going to kiss...
No, not actually, sorry.
I forgot how much you guys meme about kissing.
No.
You guys are going to have a collab on Icy's channel
to return the favour for when Emmers was away
and they did a collab on her channel.
No, they're not kissing.
Stop it.
You're not winning.
Fucking last time I tried to write that script.
Oh, they're kissing.
They're kissing.
No, they're not.
They're not kissing.
I'm not making them kiss.
The Sheeby for the harem,
just like in all of the other Seekers at this point.
Harem, fantastic news for Harem.
Sheeby is getting very close to finishing a YouTube roleplay.
That's more free bonus content on top of what she already provides.
Everyone is working their little tushies off
and they're doing fantastic.
I just hope we're avoiding burnout,
making sure no one's stressed.
I was working with Azura yesterday, fantastic.
And we were getting to the bottom of her donathon.
Now, I'm not going to say what's inside it,
but we're getting to the bottom of it.
So a graphic is going to be made soon.
I'm going to hope it's all good and Gucci and no one...
I mean, Azura did work together on it.
I suggested what I thought was a good idea
then Azura came in and helped kind of refine it
to a much higher quality of what she was interested in.
Can I just say,
God damn, if you are a belittling heart,
you are in for a fun time with her rewards, okay?
As always, I did try and focus on Mitchell Mitchell public reward.
Okay, is that enough rambling for now?
I think so.
Okay, I got my cup of tea.
I don't know, maybe I should just read Marshmallows
so I can actually have a warm cup of tea for once, right?
You're a fuck it.
I'm looking at marshmallows.
I want a warm cup of tea.
I don't think I could possibly leak any more secrets from Villalor.
That was the most ridiculous thing.
Honestly, I know we've moved on from feature.
We've moved on from features.
I'm literally one of my know or do I not count?
Am I an honorary feature, bro?
I moved on.
Hi, hi, Eastland.
Okay, just so it's rude since there are others.
Oh, no, did I miss something?
Oh, unless they want to kiss.
Yes, I'm also going to try and refine my one-on-one collab,
ASMR collabs with everyone
because I would really love to have all my collabs with Villalor
up ASMR-wise.
And then the girls can kind of start,
what would you like to do?
And then I can kind of get in there, you know?
I make conversation-wise.
Oh, my apologies.
I was like, yeah, damn, getting insulted at the fucking date.
Someone says, I love you, my rarted beloved.
I love you too, mate.
Are you?
I feel like you, as a refilling, hold more IQ than I do.
So I can't really say it.
I like the giant script idea.
I think there should be more in-character themes often
than random ones.
It's a very difficult path to lead
because if I shoehorn them into a tight,
because, you know, take Azure's giantessness, for example,
you know, it's like, right, used as a figurine,
okay, maybe in between the cleavage, okay,
maybe in the mouth, okay.
But to do, was it four times 12 is a big number?
48 audios.
In one year, 48 audios will be produced.
For them all to contain the same tag is not possible.
Now, I know you're not asking for the same tag.
I know you're asking for a little cheeky bit more of the,
is it kayfabe?
A bit more on par with the kayfabe.
I understand that, but you have to understand,
I want to drown people.
So I can't quite, you know, stick to it.
I know what you mean, but,
and I know you're also giving me the benefit
of the doubt in the same breath.
Also, speaking of role play, I'm a weirdo,
just like, yeah, bro, I'll do anything.
Fuck yeah.
See, you're the target audience.
You're the perfect motherfucker.
I think you could sprinkle them in now and then.
Yes, so, Jin was me script-wise,
and I kind of put everyone on par,
except for myself, because I'm a little fucking meme lord.
I like meme and writing and stuff like that.
It's my favorite thing to do,
literally, that membership stream move.
But yes, no, I do understand you want more
kind of in character role plays.
Yes, I comprehend.
I listen.
I want to drown people.
Literally, cramming all this content
into his mummies, becoming a content feeder.
Real and true.
For ASMR when?
You don't want to fuck it.
You get what you want.
You get what you fucking want.
Hold on.
I need the message.
I'll message on the person that drew it.
Hello.
Again.
Vibe, comma.
I hope you are well.
The pregnancy ASMR video did great,
and I'd love to do its chaos.
Possibly getting three variation artworks of war.
Of war.
There is this subject
that you are comfortable commissioning.
Question mark.
There you go.
5% profits in the pudding.
You get what you want around here.
I've sent the DM.
It is what it is.
I wheeled too much about it.
Vorkalab?
How can you vorkalab?
What?
I fucking take your head and then they take your legs?
How can you vorkalab?
Or we kiss over you?
Mummy is going to send us to the rapture,
and we love it.
Literally going to the rapture.
We deserve in her society.
You are getting bored.
This business correspondence is so unprofessional,
but when it's like,
oh no, I have to actually communicate.
Mummy, love you.
Now drink your tea.
Shit.
You got my refill.
How the fuck did you time that so well?
Scottish Vee, should we sit?
We'll be right back.
Ray Queen, I followed your Patreon.
I love it.
I'm glad you enjoy it.
May I have your consent to enjoy it?
Yes.
You have all the permission in the world.
Remember to save.
We've not even started.
I'm trying to frickin' drink this.
The vorkalab is the fight over the most tender...
Oh, the vorkalab is the fight over the most...
That makes sense.
Collab partner is you,
or in your tummy.
I have an update.
Okay.
Your dog,
or should I say our dog bowl?
Because we're both getting a dog.
So the dog bowls are coming first.
Okay?
And then the collars are coming next.
The collars said they're going to take next month,
but by the end of this month,
the dog bowls are here, okay?
So...
We're doing it.
We're being degenerates together.
Do you like soft or hard?
Definitely soft.
I'd rather keep you alive by then,
but you know, the little regurgitation,
that's all good with me.
You gave us plenty of updates about the girls,
so when's your next alternative Twitter audio today?
I'm ovulating.
I know I'm ovulating,
because slime is coming out of me.
And it's clear,
and that's when I know I'm ovulating.
So you get an audio today.
I can finally take your voice.
Hi, Stroni.
If I ever become the president,
I'd make you the secretary of transportation.
Why that position you might ask?
Because you have experience hauling
that massive cake around all day.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
It's time for prego.
Oh, there you go.
Inkling time.
Hi, Stroni.
Just some bio shock lore.
Oh, I do love a bit of video game lore.
You may have missed,
well, in the panic because you were playing.
The scientist and raptor put a sea slug
in the head of the little girls,
turning them into little sisters.
And the sea slugs,
Vergey, Volna.
Thank you for becoming a member.
Enjoy the pregnancy,
and all the other stuff.
There's quite a few of them.
Sea slug Adam in the blood.
And as a result,
people ended them for the Adam.
Oh, that's why the little sisters
are in so vulnerable.
So the brainwashed guys and weapons
to protect the little sister,
and the guy talking to you in this level
is unresponsive.
I'm going to keep him alive
because I'm trying to be nice.
I don't like the heat.
Wait, mommy.
Quick, let me ink in your teeth first.
Honey tea.
Oh, yeah, you want to give me honey tea?
No breed, only pregnant.
Oh, wait, no, I said that wrong.
Only breed, no pregnant.
The multiplayer in BioShock 2 is amazing.
Wait, is this the line?
Can I play BioShock 2 with you guys?
How is my Pog wafter?
That's amazing.
I love that.
Doesn't Pog mean fat ass white girl?
Broly legend.
Time for us all to ink so we get a chance.
You have to wait until the 10th of October.
Gotta make myself clear.
You must hold until the 10th of October.
Thank you, Broly legend.
Ink soon.
Hello, Momay, how are you?
Yuppers, I think it is.
Yeah.
Have you ever eaten squid ink pasta?
I've known two months for feet.
Well, you want feet bake?
I already did feet.
I did a whole shroom dedicated to feet.
My ripping my tights got clipped,
but I'm probably going to turn it into a short.
Arisa's probably going to like her eyes are going to roll out of her skull
when I say that she'll be like, yeah, I know what you're doing.
Yeah, yeah.
According to your slimy dude, let me be clear.
There's a few days after my older pals wedding,
man, everyone's getting married.
What the fuck?
That's it.
We just need to get married to show everyone up right now.
But wait a minute.
Hey, Momay, as refunds can clean the aftermath of the audio if you want,
did you like my panties?
I got really embarrassed to actually show that picture,
but it's kind of, it's just what happens.
I literally unironically inked myself.
What's with the 10th of October?
So the 10th of October is my birthday.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Two months.
Zarian.
So long, sir.
I never said thank you so long, sir.
Our Zarian, thank you.
Two months.
Love you, Stranny.
Love you.
Strong so too.
No, not my strong so.
I just remembered what it means.
The pic was hot.
My birthday's the 10th of October,
but my doughnathon isn't related to needing to move out or new PC parts
or anything of that nature.
My doughnathon is related to hiring six more people to sexually harass with no HR.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you, Rockstar, for the extended membership.
I become a Rockstar.
But yeah.
If we go get married, let's do it.
We do it live.
My doughnathon is related to the confirmation of Gen2's production
because it takes quite a very long time to make
and it also costs a pretty penny as well.
But that's for me too, Erin.
Not for you to worry about.
Vealer is simply just Stranny's harem.
Oh, shit.
I say harem now because it's TV.
How am I even supposed to say...
Thank you for becoming the extended membership.
Stranny Hogs, Stranny Love Heart.
Thanks again.
For the two month extended membership.
Can I invest in Gen2?
Every, you know, tip membership, et cetera,
actually is technically an investment into Gen2.
I'm not even fucking kidding.
As for the clipping program.
Oh my God, more leaks.
Thank God I was drinking this cup of tea, more leaks.
The clipping program.
I, if my services are correct,
and by services I mean management is communicated to me,
10 people have been contacted, please do check.
Although one of you, who I won't be naming names,
didn't put your correct discord down.
And I'm not sure how to navigate getting you added.
I hope you follow, if you follow the main Vealer account,
I can maybe get them to be in there.
But one of you, that clips is often,
they didn't put down your correct discord ad,
and management are like, what do we do now?
And I'm like, well, you're gonna have to deal with it.
Whoever you are.
I don't know if I'm allowed to name them.
They clip the girls often.
If you guys come up with a name, I'll confirm it.
How about that?
Something, something, did a highlight reel of all
a ridiculous collapse.
There, do you know who it is now?
For those of you who watched all the highlight
of those who come up with this stuff.
But yes, 10 people have been contacted.
It's gonna be trialed for a month.
We're gonna see what that, fondle a bosom.
You know what, you're done.
Wait, the leak.
Ink vesters, if you will, true.
I almost choked on my tea.
All right, who's ready to go into the rapture?
Me, me, I'm ready to go into the rapture.
I can't wait.
Right, this game is...
Oh, my controller said, hold on.
I need to put my controller back online.
Excuse me right now.
She's leaking information as much as she's leaking ink.
Somebody plug that home.
Someone said that, they really plug that home
and I'm like, excuse you.
This is literally where I leaked from.
Where else am I supposed to leak from?
Okay, we're good, we're good.
Thank you, the beauty lord, for the super chat.
Right, you're ready.
Okay, every 10 minutes, you must say,
Shawnee, save.
Okay, now I am, just for those of you who didn't
catch up with yesterday's stream, please don't worry.
I have accidentally played this full section before.
I bet you've forgotten it all.
Oh, God, I feel like a noob again.
Oh, God, it's been so long.
We did play, but unfortunately, the game crashed
right at the end of the mission
and did not remember a single thing.
Hold on.
Right, so they're fully leveled up, that's fine.
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh, my God.
I'm ready for Shawnee to rapture me.
Rapture's all over you.
Okay.
Okay, unfortunately, ooh.
Right, let's scavenge, scavenge him.
Give me all them bullets.
Give me that.
Give me that tommy gun bullets.
I picked up caliber rounds.
Right, sorry, let me just get a little familiar again.
My apologies.
Oh, my God, I'm ready for Shawnee to rapture me.
Did I pop your cherry?
Dragon Karma, thank you for your cherry.
Yoinkers, my no.
Okay, right, let's scavenge what we can.
We got armor, piercing rounds, 20.
That was actually very worth it.
Right, okay.
Oh, wait, hold on.
What did I say?
Oh, please hurry, Daddy.
Anyway, let's just grab this real quick.
Are you a master of research?
Get the most out of your damage while you research.
Oh, no, I've lost all my little slots.
Oh, no, I forgot.
I forgot.
Oh, right.
Okay, we're being introduced to the lab.
Hello.
My name is Gilbert Alexander.
Hello, we received a call about a serious leaking problem.
Where's the problem?
Where's the Mario Brothers?
Thank you, Mario Brothers, for being concerned about my leakage problem.
I can't believe you lost all your slots.
What?
I know.
What happened last stream?
Unfortunately, the game crashed right at the end of the level.
I'm going to look for slugs.
Oh, my goodness.
I didn't recall.
I'm looking for slugs.
Eat slots.
That's a really particular reference.
Okay, we picked up 10, Adam, for grabbing that.
Hi, Adam.
Sorry, I just want to mess with you so badly if you're called Adam right now.
Everyone's like, man, I wish the video game was my first legal name.
And then everyone's like, there'll be like one refling called Isaac.
And they're like, oh, do you want to play Binding of Isaac?
Oh, I know you're so addicted to it.
I'm sure you want to play Binding of Isaac.
Isaac, Isaac, Isaac.
What other games?
There's other characters called, I'm sorry.
I'm just looking around for slugs.
Okay, I got one slug.
I think that's all we're getting out of this little adventure.
30 minutes lost, but 30 minutes.
Well, I was worried in case you didn't want to play.
I was going to play this offline, so I wasn't repeating myself,
but maybe we can do a bit better this time around.
Sorry, I'm getting very scared.
We're already saving teeth.
Okay, right.
So we're going to be introduced to this naughty, naughty robot.
And he's so naughty.
And he's getting farted on.
We've got a hacked art.
So anyway, do you want to look?
Hi, Isaac, are you going to bind me up?
Hi.
Are you glitched out?
Nope.
You're fired.
No, I'm not.
I'm a cute little worker.
See.
Okay, there's a bit of a fight in this room, but that's okay.
I'm ready.
Where did she go?
Where'd she go?
I don't know how to cancel the electricity.
Oh, there you go.
It was the other bumper.
No, not me.
I'm so confused.
I have played this.
Oh, my God.
My stream got copyright yesterday, by the way.
Because of a 10 second fragmented audio.
And I swear if it's because of that teleprompter.
Whoa.
Have we researched these guys?
Oh, we haven't.
Right.
Get the rivet gun out.
That telekinesis?
How the fuck do I have telekinesis?
I don't use telekinesis.
Okay, I've already researched everyone here.
Okay, so I'm starting to understand the research.
I've got playing games.
This game audio always breaks my brain.
Is it too loud?
Are we all happy?
Actually, I need to stop using the ice because the ice means I can't scavenge their corpses.
And it's putting me at detriment.
Oh, my money.
Oh, I'm sorry.
My apologies.
Okay, right.
We're not going to do that.
We're going to do this.
Alex, the great.
Oh, hell, that has to be Gil Alexander.
Same man who left that message we're following.
He sounds mad as a March Hare now.
It's always a gamble.
Is that my foot?
Oh, sorry.
I thought there was a big daddy.
I've got a shotgun box.
I do.
We're going to muck about with shotguns a little bit.
Oh, I forgot about this.
Oh, yeah.
This is that anticlimactic fight.
So they actually did make this part easy in the game.
But then the rest of the game is super hard.
Stranny, when you kill them while frozen,
they drop boxes with their loot in it.
I never saw the boxes.
I can't seem to find that box when they're frozen.
It must go to Spain because I can't even find it.
Wait, in infinite, there's a part where the girls love to have fun.
Excuse me?
What happens in infinite?
In Bioshock Infinite?
Is there a scene that we need to see?
Oh, it's the big bad man.
He's coming.
When they freeze, they drop nothing.
That's awful.
Oh, I don't have any of those.
I'm just spamming this.
Ooh, increased damage.
The Alpha series is vulnerable to armor-fiercing rounds.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I'm getting slightly better, dare I declare.
Wait, what do you mean I'm really confident playing this section
because I've actually played it before?
What? No!
What do you mean I'm so cocky now because I've played this section?
What?
No, that's crazy.
I'm always the same when I play games, okay?
Me or cocky now because then it comes up again.
Only a room that will copyright this stream.
Literally, I had a tent.
The stream was six hours long and YouTube's like,
sorry, ineligible and all that.
I have been exposed to a massive dose of substance addict.
By the time you hear this, I will live on.
Wait, no, I don't need to take that out to hack it though.
Oh my God, that's so skinny.
Penetrate?
You're actually really okay now because I know what to do.
Save every 10 minutes.
Okay, you'll need to tell me when...
Hey, hey, hey, Krusty Kram.
Hey, hey, hey.
Okay, look at this.
She even made the same joke.
I'm sorry.
That old Mayra reminded me of...
Shoot to her.
What? Jesse passed away?
From Pokemon?
From what? She must have been so young.
Okay, I'm going to save his reservoir head.
Misty?
Oh, cancer for fuck's sake, man.
Jesse and Misty was the same voice actress.
I didn't even know.
Sorry, I'm going to scavenge while the gameplay happens.
Basically, we're being locked out by him
because he won't let us talk in the same time.
So I'm just scavenging.
Hi, hi, Misty.
Thanks for joining.
We're just assisting the passing of the Pokemon V.
Cancer took both the Japanese and English views.
All I'm saying is that when they finally come out
with the microplastic reports,
it's all I'm saying.
All I'm saying is that's actually so fucking cool.
Sorry, but cancer is absolutely alright.
See if you can find some way to sabotage his control
of building security.
Security?
I like when I'm called Delta.
Damn right, I'm Big D.
I'm Big Delta.
Oh, I'll be your daddy tonight.
55 is like incredibly young.
Incredibly young.
Hmm.
Okay, right, we've got a bubble, so that's fine.
We're going to grab this little chickadee.
We're going to make her a problem.
Where are you? Up here or down here?
Hi, pumpkin space.
I'm not mean.
I'm mean there, motherfucker.
Sorry, hold on. Let me get a picture real quick.
Let me get a picture.
Oh wait, not a rivet. The spear is better, I think.
Oh, this is that fanny that puts down
all those little turret things.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
I'm getting brave. I'm getting cocky
because I've played this section before.
I'm getting cocky.
Okay, we're just going to screw him down.
Whoa! Not too cocky, not too cocky.
I'm a fucking caliber.
Fucking hell.
All right, pumpkin, you know what I hate.
On you go.
There was a Japanese V that was 55 in English.
What the fuck in the hell? What's going on?
I don't want to see the algae space.
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
I need you to pick up some atom for me, darling.
Okay, right.
Yes, you are correct, right.
You be a doll and grab that as fast as you possibly can
and then I'm going to get tons of good stuff for it, okay?
Yes, yes, yes, angel, angel.
That's great, kid, don't get cocky.
Literally worse than Star Wars and out here.
We actually need to watch Star Wars, you know that.
Should we watch on May 4th?
Oh, no, I was going to play LEGO.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Star Wars?
Should we watch on May 4th?
Maybe we should just watch the movies on May 4th.
Bob and Weave, Momay, Bob and Weave.
I'm trying so hard, Miroa.
Thank you for the extended membership.
Literally suckin' stuff.
Fucking bad.
How did I keep accidentally...
Great, okay, that's one.
Oh, what was that?
Oh, that is what I want.
I need to try and get him
and then I can do more damage against him and...
Oh, sorry, I'm doing a bit of rubbish.
I maybe should have bought some...
Animal bullets!
No!
Why did he just accept that?
Honestly.
It had literally just some...
and cruise damage.
That's what I want to see, baby!
Leave her alone.
She's main to deal with.
She's mine, not yours!
Ugh!
Wait, hold on.
Hold on!
Hold on.
I'm literally...
I'm getting all these upgrades
because I didn't understand the mechanics.
But now I do.
I'm learning.
Okay, the angel's done.
That's good, darling.
Oh, my God!
What was that?
Okay, you get on my back, darling.
Nicely so.
Death Jar Jar.
Okay, there is one more
but we're going to scavenge a little bit.
We just need to pick up more ammo.
Yeah, see, those boxes do get left behind.
But the other stuff doesn't seem to like it so much.
Mummy would drill well for the heavens.
Well, I do have a frozen...
benefit to my...
my gun.
If that's looking at me.
There we go.
Oh, I've got a few bullets off of that.
Okay, let's go
and purchase some munitions
and then I will let her grab the last body that she wants
and then I'll pop her away
and the horse, which is nice and sweet.
And that's for anything else major.
Okay, that's where we're going to spend the point.
Vending machine, hack it, and then...
bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
Okay, there we go.
We have 400, almost 800 dollars to imagine.
We'll just buy everything out now.
Uh, that's the...
caliber?
Sure, why not?
Wow, I can hold so much more gun stuff.
No, don't talk to me.
I'm gaming so hard right now.
Plasma needed that fill.
Is it discount ostrich?
Yes, it is.
They did not handle friends.
Yep, there's the angel.
Pupsie, off you go.
I'll protect you.
They sent the wrong discord so if they want to resend it, just...
Resend it.
Because we cannae, I do.
Okay.
Me when I know I have tons of ammo.
Sorry, darling.
I'm a bit distracted.
Fuckin' hell, you need to calm down for one.
Stop it.
R-r-r-r-r-r-r-r-r!
Me when I've fully ammo'd up and fully levelled up.
I need to get...
I'm just screaming down
Leave her alone. Leave her alone. She's my responsibility not yours
Hold on me real good you bitch
Fuck me bitch
You're good is that yummy
Is it yummy?
Yeah, that was yummy
Yes, it's bedtime. You have done a fantastic job little pumpkin space
Nope you are perfectly safe as long as you're on my back and then we're gonna pop you away
And then we're going to save before we pop you away in case a big sister comes along because that is the reason
Reflings mommy's gaming she's getting so good. Thank you stash power
Literally, I think I just need to sleep on like the mechanics like once I sleep and I understand like I get stronger when I
It was some
Which the boy would obey in an order obey
Oh
That scared me I crouched I got so scared I crouched
A volunteer
Let me in
I'll be you
Save time save time
Saving content, please don't turn off your pitter. I won't turn off my pitter
Right no one better jump scare me
Other than the fish
Oh
Okay, that's a lot health station. I don't need but thank you for your offer
Right pumpkin space
Once we've scavenged all the bodies. I'm gonna put you in your hidey-hole. So you're all nice and safe
Oh, I'll take these don't mind the fast-cavenge easy jump
You're getting bombed
Touch that
You're free from the sea slugs they will compel you no more
You're more than
Oh
One second darling one second hold on your main you're literally main bonk
Something's going for me
Was that him that did that to me
Okay, he's mine. I am starting a bumblebee army
What is going on?
Great, I'm not starting an army anymore because I'm getting
Oh, they come with bullets. Oh, they give bullets that's pretty smart
The alarm I don't know where you even say off that alarm was it cuz I destroyed his thing
Appears I am severely mistaken. Oh, right. Let's check the map
Press Y destroy the signal really attached to the front of a bought shutdown machine located in the plasmas
theater a
Movie theater something interior alligator
All right pumpkin spaces now that we have
Ah
Dom hi, Adam. Sorry. I'm fucking way if you actually are called Adam so badly right now, okay gene tonic
We're gonna put a load of shite on
So what one?
That's all good two three
Four and five. I think with my maximum. I'm gonna go check at the gene center. Oh
You know it interior crocodile alligator, I drive a shiverly
Damage research there we go
So we now have put everything on that we actually own. Oh, wait. No, it's put that freaking ice thing on hold on
Hold on. Sorry. I need to take the ace one off and sorry not the ace one the drill one
It one of them makes your drill the only thing
Drills specialist. Yes. Sorry. Let me take that off. I ain't good at the game like that chief
I ain't good at the game like that. Okay, and I'm go to the machine and we will
Become a master of electricity with the power of an electrical storm. I don't know. I kind of like incinerate
I'm a bit of an incinerate that
decoy security boozehound
I
Extra nutrition, I think some said medical expert is good for me because I suck
Walking inferno take less damage from fire
But I didn't really get put on fire much cute. Oh, he'll stations also reveal it hypnotize two and three can be fun
Oh, you can make the enemy go on your side or is that only time one?
I feel and I need to take a nap rest well starting remember that you have Adam if you like the bumblebee's invest in a tonic that
Heals and names long heels and names my bumblebee
Hacking up raises its max hell
Your electrical attack
You admit a burst of electricity when struck honestly
Increase research bonuses even more allowing to progress faster. I mean, that doesn't sound that repair a name handyman
Okay, I need to buy another slot for it
We're getting a bit low on Adam though
Gene tonic slot, yes
I
Think maybe we should do a health and Eve next, you know that
Against I'll do two health upgrades and then we'll wrap it up there
No take this off
Stop putting it on take this off put handyman on instead. Okay. I can now name you apartment
Repair come here
I
Deactivate Melanie what are you called?
Benjamin shows them show me your Benjamin your big sexy bomb show me that big Benji
Okay, so I can't have six medkits and six evils which is actually quite nice
What are you a caliber very free for caliber put my songs into hell
Right fear was to the west. Okay, let's go
Mommy trying to respond will be sweet little bumblebee. I know what you want from me
Okay, now this is a prank I can't reach that one, right you two ready for this fight ahead. I hope you are
We are in fontane's lair. I
Can't pick it up because I'm actually full of ammo for once a Christmas miracle. I am Melanie gun bought of strong a
What is my function? Oh my god?
Now you better leave my little box alone
Oh my god, I'm doing howie. I hurt my toes in the war
Oh, something shiny. Oh, I'm full. Oh, I'll grab it because I'm no coming back
I'm not coming back. You know me gene bank. I don't need gene
When the game starts giving you needs
Why are you giving me granite? No, I'm not the kitty. Why did they always put in a cake?
Stop putting dead animals
Wait, I can hit machines and it'll give me stuff for free
I can hit machines for wait my bumblebees are locked outside. Let them come in right now
What are you bandages?
Oh
I'm singing hi, I'm strony Cotters and I'll sing Halo for you all
Save moment, right mommy's saving
Bum bum bum bum
We ain't having no glitches this game even if the game shuts down. I ain't gonna make a difference to me
Yeah, but you're going to break them and then you can never use them after that
So use them when I'm walking away. Oh, no my microphone. How are the people gonna hear? All right?
I just need to really announce a
Oh
Chat disconnected oh shit
Why chatting on screen
How long ago did the chat disconnect wait what must I feel like I'm supposed to do some
We did chat literally, I don't know why
She's humming brick and gin
Like three minutes ago, okay, wait, well, I do my challenge green thing hold on how then I can do my
And then chat on screen and then I need to select the correct window
Oh
There you go
Okay, hold on. Let me I can't even take you guys just take tests because I can't I'm still saying that my YouTube again
I'll just put it right there. We love
I'm checking oh
Something's happening
It's happening you're doing it. Oh, that's the bottom of the chart. That's why that's why it's what
I do like that, but yeah, yeah, well, that looks good enough
professional by the way
We did it
You you do you want to fight me? I'll fight you
Don't be shy rip your head out and fart on your pubes
How about you sir? No, he's positively rigid
Make a more it is
So more professional than YouTube literally YouTube broke everything my redirects haven't been working my thumbnails have been bugging out
my
Just everything
What what happened? Why did you go in the stratosphere?
Why did you do that? I don't know why she did that
Hold on hold on hold on
Where's she going?
Got you
Oh, I'm out. Sorry. I'm out right hold on don't move
Natural camouflage. What the fuck this is
No, I don't need natural camouflage. No, I did not share with a rocket launcher. Are you joking?
Oh
What's going on, I think they're like walking on that and the physics are gonna freeze
Behold physics you broke the game again you rolled ragdolter right she's supposed to tell
Now
Delta's gonna faint like a big daddy
Physics it's more of a suggestion in this game than anything else
Absolutely warped is our soul
Yeah
You couldn't stand when we stuck you into that get up
Give me more freebies
Right we did it I'm not just eat for free
And then we'll scavenge and pick up all our loot because we got loads of loot from these guys
I
Don't use the first aid kit
I'm pretty sure the week alpha is supposed to be target practice for multiplayer
What was the multiplayer like did you go against the like in-game stuff for?
There's it more right you're shining as soon as I do that
I
Just look everything I blow that up to smithereens
Now just look all these people. Thank you for dying
That helps me survive in my quest
Okay, next we need to
Deal with anyone that's respond
Is it upstairs now? Okay destroy the signal the offices are off to the left of the marketing department, which I believe is upstairs. I
Really wish they didn't have to be spawned everything
How am I heartless bro, I'm not done anything stop it you're telling fibbers. I'm not heartless
I
Can show you what heartless group really looks like
Save save oh shit, sorry
Sorry, sorry. I'm getting so I'm still getting into it's cuz I know kind of what to do. I'm like, oh, yeah, I can do this
Oh, yeah, mr. Cram
Okay, there's a little thing to pick up here
Have I maxed out okay, I've maxed out on the teleport people as well. Can you take your gun out please?
Maybe this game isn't as hard as I first thought it was and it was because I'm actually just a brain lit
And I just wasn't doing it right, but I'm I'm calm for handing
Actually quite enjoy the the like photograph system makes you like stronger against the enemies. I think that's like a really nice detail
Ah, I remember
Mummy's learning it only took me what seven hours of playing the game and being right at the end
Mm-hmm
I'll let it spark again and then I'll spray it down
Sinclair
Fuck you bitch
I
Was Gavin Jim we get on the dollar now that your program are having learning understood the mechanic yet literally
Oh, it took me what six hours. I don't know why like because you guys were telling me like oh, this is how it works
But I don't know it just takes my brain like longer to comprehend something. I hope that's understandable
like in a sentence
but
Like it does it just takes me a bit longer and I think because I slept on it like I slept on the the fact toys of
Like oh, this is how this game mechanic works
Yeah, you basically didn't want to understand the game rushed everything I
Don't know if I'm supposed to mess with this. I think I really let me touch it much I
Guess if I chase it, it'll actually give me the reward for it's like a passive teleport thing. It's my guess
Oh, I just look shocked. I got scared from it. I
Like the hand detail as well when you got like fire and you did well regardless of me being a brain
You still
Have a nice swap into telekinesis, I don't
They hear a daddy I
Don't hear the Wayne so
That's me. I'm hearing my own first step. I'm like
That was a bit close to think
I
Hear something jingling
We'll keep the shotgun out for a little bit I can hear this here blow it up to smithereens go complete
Okay, what can we scavenge from the death?
Oh
More alcohol
Okay, he blew up because he's super angry at me, but we can go into the others like first aid kit
Okay, I grabbed it. Oh it's safe. Oh, there's two. There's three. Oh, no
Okay, I'm not doing that again, so I'm not like it as a game. Okay, we did it
She was on any percent speed one that takes pro skills
Okay, I'm quite sad
Maybe I'll pull out the old caliber the old ball and chain caliber since it's literally the best thing ever
Oh, you're mistaken miss lamp, right? I'm no tire and I'm the protector of little sisters spawner
Well, the purchase a few more caliber
To literally spring down with that gun
I'm no time. I don't even know why I'm here. You know what? I just woke up here 10 years later
Be nice to me. Okay. I'm a bit disorientated
F11 is quicksave if this grant
Failed to load the quicksave your mother imagine if I got teleported back because of your fanny and about young man
I fell for your prank. I trusted you
You almost killed us you almost killed us
There's a switch in here
Okay, now we get to go to the letter our border for it really you my labor it's sorry
I don't know where I'm supposed to go. I'm just following the arrow
I'm not taking HP damage for this
Help me five two five four
What I'm not sure I want to take it but you taught vending machine well, I mean I guess
What is this
Five
I
Not a slave. I'm a big daddy
I can be your daddy. It doesn't really work like that. I think I can be your mommy though
That was very strange, I did appear to actually take damage from that fate that wasn't really a fate, but I'm not mattering. Oh
He's trying to scare me because it's working
Someone is angry at me. Oh
That's right. They all kept coming down here, but they wouldn't leave me alone. Oh
No, they're fully
Okay, there's quite a lot of enemies that are gonna come down this corridor if I remember correctly
You already are her description of attire appears to me. Am I the baddie?
Wait, I didn't pay attention too much
Do you want to be the baddie?
I can make you play the bad guy
Oh, no missy. What am I gonna do?
You won't let me escape without giving you something. You need some information from me
Why are you so close?
You need to calm them
Can I progress or am I still in trouble?
Why does it keep going to telekinesis? I'm not telling it to wait bumblebee. Where did you come from?
Are you okay?
Hey
Are you okay buddy?
What happened? I don't even know where you went for half the map your map problem now, though
I'm quite happy of it
Stardays over using the 50 cal and the alphas is written for them. I need to swap to shotgun instead
Okay, I will remember that next thing
I do have frag grenades at least
You
They tracked you down literally only took the whole game for them to find me
Yes
Don't start with me woman. I have a family
And I don't know that's my favorite thing
It's literally my favorite thing when you guys are like I was literally about to go for like dinner or like I was literally about to
Go shopping and I need to wait for it to go away. That's my favorite fucking thing. Sorry, but I'm so happy
Bye bumblebee. Thank you for your service
Hey, thank you the very lord for the super jet 10 minutes of time wait. Are you guys got timers on your
Like and or something
You must have a timer on your end. You're so efficient. Right. We're gonna look for some
Um
Mummy keeps her reeflings at home to keep them aroused the whole time literally I'll go outside for you
You can live the perfect knee. I'll make you chicken
Nuggets every night. Is there a slog around here?
No, uh, oh maybe
No, that's just coral. Um
And I feed you and then I give you a smart every night to fall asleep too and give you body massages
When you're soaring tired. I didn't okay. I actually didn't see any
I don't think there's any slugs this time. I think I don't think they always put a slug in the outside map
So I guess we'll just go for it
Good thing it's already evening in the EU
I can watch with a stiffy in the comfort mode home. That's amazing
Right, is there a slug? I feel like there should be a slug. Oh, I could have scavenged him. Sorry
I can like fully breathe under war, right?
I'm not gonna cause any problems dilly dallying
I was at me to be born to
As I recall from my time to a business with the owners is that oxy fill station out
There's just a front for a kind of hidden passage leading down below if lambs hide an eleno from you. That's where she'll be
I can't eat. Sorry. I don't see any slugs this time
But
I feel like they would put it really obvious like they wouldn't want to hate it that much from you
Yeah, okay. I don't think there was a sluggy one here this time, but that's okay
Okay
Asa my roleplay of you taking care of okay. Yeah, don't ask for like a nice cozy roleplay not absolutely
No questions
Why do I not like this I can't seem to recall
It appears I am rather terrified of what follows
Oh god, he's giving me news
Wait, what happens? Okay, I think it's safe until the lights come on
Okay, I'm afraid the lights in here sting my eyes
It's safe until the lights come on it's safe until the lights come on it's safe until the lights come on
I'm one of the lights for here. Okay, I can do it. I can do it. It's okay. I'm allowed to be scared
I'm allowed to be terrified. I'm allowed to be mortified and what the fuck is going on in that chamber. It's okay
Okay, there we go
Okay, I'm allowed to be scared I'm allowed to be scared
So fear and I knew up here. I didn't look at him properly. Don't touch the glass. We needed someone to be host to all that
Just running on fun taking care of 20th anniversary
Sounds like a fun time to me
Can you try pressing f12?
Oh, wow it does work. Okay f12
Whatever you may have seen inside the tank that was indeed me
I didn't see it. I'm afraid of Eleanor Lamb will be less physical, but no less grotesque
This tank for deep sea life is the ideal way to
Dispose of me, but first you must retrieve enough adam infused plant life to rule me out
The slugs feed on the stuff and it's all
Why are you thanking me? You're helping me. No crash
Sample here, so you know what to look for
Okay, so I need some flowers
I can do that
Oh, not good obliot obliot obliot
I
Didn't uh, I recorded him. What?
I recorded him. I didn't even hurt him myself. Wait, they're fanning each other
I don't did you mean to do that? I don't think he did
Is
I think they hurt each other and I got the benefit of it
Okay, get to Eleanor you're gonna need one from alex the great in there first things first we got a pin down
Find those plants he mentioned and lure him back out
Oh
Wait, these are teleport guys. No, right. I fully leveled up. I just need the other
I just need the other guys
And the alpha guys
Alpha can you one
Um, sorry, that was I don't know why I said that unprompted. Whoa, what do you mean? Whoa, whoa, stop
He's fucking scaring me. Jesus. I didn't even see it
Oh
No, that was a way back up wait
No, it is this way
Sorry, I just remembered that little mean thing god. Why have I been so bad right? Okay, that's fine. I'm always gonna do that
Right. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I come in here and then the game pretends that I'm allowed to leave
prank
Get pranked. I'm not allowed to leave. Oh my god. I got pranked so hard
With the heck I must just grab it. Oh, it's shining
Uh, it's got it's also got an audio cue and you know how it's like big and violently, you know glowing. Yeah
Oh, no, I'm so surprised
Just for those who are coming in I have played this my game unfortunately crashed
So I don't know what's coming up just for this level though. I don't know what happens
Does anyone need a photo taken of them, please be honest with me. I can't
Yeah, nice try mate
Nice try
Oh, he threw a knee at me
Give me all those supplies right now
Poor things what a life marching around playing daddy until some splice of manage to kill off their sister
And then if the coma doesn't take them they turn maniac just like a tourist trap
I'm trying to take a picture and sell it to you
We better get you to elinor on the double
Crank of john begins to tear itself apart
The compulsion to find elinor will drive you to madness or coma
I'm sorry for what happens next little one. It's nothing personal
Greatest sense
And yet you persist. Oh, I'm persistent. All right. I'm fucking persistent. All right
It's okay pumpkin spaces, okay
I'm you'll feel a hell of a lot better once I'm
Got you what you want
All right, you do your thing. We'll go get the other body
Yes angel, yes
careful
They are gonna come over honeypot, but just
Set up traps. I probably should but never fall though
Like I feel like by the time I'm finished right up
No, they're fully done. So it's just like daddies that are attached to
Little sisters that
Hear them
It's probably worse when I can directionally hear the enemy, but I don't see them like that
Subsequently actually like worse
Like I
I think I'm going to have to upgrade to fire safe
Unzip them just to say the last interest in terminology. I did a bit more than unzip the enemies
I make them feel real different. All right
I
Nice try buddy get the fuck out of here. Oh my god, that's so disorientating when they do that
Are you done darlin can you hurry up and chug chug your cola you're taking a fucking what saying darlin
Ah
I'm trying I'm trying
Okay, maybe I should have stayed up traps. I can't whoa. Why did my aim just blew up?
I can't believe the reeflings were right again. I should have stayed up
Get out of here
Okay, she's chugging her cola that's good
Oh, you're a pumpkin space geez my goodness
I hear like
They hear lots of brolling that isn't
Right I seem to have a lot of rivets so maybe I should start using this a bit more
Although it's kind of a pump pump pump, you know, and I'm more of a give me the route to shoot
All right, where's your next body
Uh, I don't but I'm glad you do because like
All right, I was gonna say where are you taking me right? It's back in here. Okay. I will set up traps
I
Okay, let's do what here
Here here
Ah
Nope, you're fine. You're safe. Uh, I really wish they didn't I probably that's the only thing
I don't like about these kind of games is it really should be they don't respawn in the area that you've cleared out
because that implies they're like climbing around or
Doing something rather obtuse. I guess how I would describe it
Right surely that's enough surely that's enough fucking pre
Put down traps, right?
Copium I bet you they're all gonna come the wrong way
Hi, I see. Hi snowberries
We're playing, um bioshock we have we're replaying a section because unfortunately my game bugged out
Uh, we're just playing a section. We're just getting a little sister to get as much adam as she wants
Um
Is this the
Hope you guys are doing okay
I'm I'm fortunately I'm not very good at this game. So I'm very distracted in terms of communication
But I hope I see had a fantastic stream. I actually don't know what she was doing today
Uh, I saw her tweet out about the
Something exciting which I'm not spoiling but I saw her tweet about it and she's really happy about it and she's happy
I'm happy. So I hope you guys are looking forward to that
Unless she said what it was
Sorry, give me just a second
God
I'm oh, jeez
I didn't mean I meant heavy river
Okay, she got a cooler right time to take you back home. All right
Are we gonna be together again daddy? She was sharing her stalker story
I see
What
Is everything okay daddy's a messenger. Is she okay or is she like giggling at a
She'll probably want to save after putting the losses. Yeah, in case the
Sponsor
Let me scavenge everything right f12 to save okay, and then away you go home
He later earlier
In a while crocodile
She was mercy when she was a teenager. Okay. Oh, she was laughing. I see. I mean if you cook this
Yeah, I'll make a yander short of her
The girls are whispering father. They've left you a present at the gatherers garden
Take it that's full of money. I think I'm actually full of money
I'm trying to like scavenge everything, but it's like you're full. You're full
No quiet. No quiet
Oh, you managed right you manage. Okay, she's safe. I'm satisfied
Please forgive
No, you're not too late. Oh, we're just making sure the we sisters are right. Oh, hi pumpkin
Spice
Are you do you need?
I'll give you an escort just to make sure everything's okay
Thank you for the gift. I hope you feel better soon
And all that hope rehab goes well for you a little
Okay, you see there's an animation here
Ian you manage him everything arrives precisely when he needs to okay, she's safe
Uh, I think this is why I'd rather put inferno on right if my money
Eh
What
I just wanted to buy some stuff from that machine, but I guess no what the fuck
If you're a little helper keeps getting an interrupt tell him to get a move on with demanding father
Man she gives a ton of books. What 300 Adam
Real is unlocked
We need one more and then that's fully unlocked. Okay
We can do
Incinerate, I don't know. I'm kind of I'm a bit biased towards incinerate right now, but I actually don't have enough any 300
Every time we hack you keen stuff tiger parenting honestly though
I
Didn't even need plastic like I hardly swap between them. I like
I don't know if I'm better just piling it into right. I'll do incinerate too because that does damage over time, which I really like
I know ice is okay. I'll take off spirit man
Um, then we'll just do even health. I guess
If it's the wrong choice, I do apologize, but you are watching someone play the game for the first time to suck morsel
I don't know what you want. I don't know what you want from me. I don't know what is going on there
I just want to hack this machine and buy stuff from it
This is buyout
Okay, I have developed a new set of behavioral constraints. Dr. Alexander will live to promote the common good
His love and loyalty shall be spread evenly across the entire human race
For me that is discipline at great personal cost
For him at last
It will be instinct
Can we get my belt?
Right, we have incinerate too. Let's see how we do that. I might get walloped in the back by that twat behind us, but
Before you all right
Okay
I see it anti-personnel rose. Hmm. Let me save before entering this room
I
What is dr. Lam yapping about goddamn?
I can't remember what happened
Yeah, I do like the damage over time that
Did she dive into the water to unfire herself?
Sorry, that wasn't an english thing
Oh, it's a fucking ball under here. I remember now
An a plus for that that was bizarre she dived into the
To go so I can't believe it. They didn't make these the most
Easiest enemies in game. I'm so insolent right now. There's these log under here. Be honest
Oh
There's a bubbles here
I'ma just let them clear out mr. Bubbles first
Can I get points for them attacking him?
Oh, wow, I can if he takes damage by them it counts as me giving them damage
Oh wait, I think you guys said I was using this too much
I can't fucking see shape don't worry if you can't see nothing else because I can't see nothing either
I
Can't see nothing that I pumpkin spice
That big daddy has a audio diary the one back there
Oh, he's well
Two birds one
I'll let her capture it and then I'll go in my inventory to listen to the audio log. That's how it works, right?
Sorry, I can have done that
It's a shit. It's a shit. Sorry
Oh
Stop going in the water. What the heck me like all fires amazing also me when they actually act like their own fire
I love that fray unzip them just like I'll unzip your bowls
She can't get put on fire right no
Oh
Whoa, what what?
You're scaring me
I can hear someone behind the door the violence intensified they are this one time
No, I'm the one who controls the fire
I'm sorry
Why is the music so intense?
Well, I can hear him. Yeah
Oh
Whoa, sorry, I didn't expect another
Okay, I seem ow
Is that everything
I don't
I
If you shock the splicers the little sisters sometimes say that they're dancing. Oh, that's cute
Is that good
Are you telling them I'm the best daddy ever that's cute
All right, well, let me in the food. Oh, I can hear the sunflower look can you hear the tingles?
All right, I'm going to scavenge very quickly because that's quite a lot of enemies gala enemies
But we're doing it like we're actually
I don't I don't know where darlin back that way. Okay. We'll go get we'll grab it. We'll grab it in a minute. Give us a sec
Give us a sec
Um
I hate to be cocky, but I think I think I understand the mechanics now. I can't believe it
I feel confident
Is that another daddy?
Is he supposed to spawn there?
I'm no touching them
I've still got a girl on me
As it happens. Okay, so
Um
I guess we'll just go with it. I mean sure
Maybe mr. Bubbles might help
Right, I'll let her do that. I'll get rid of her. I'll save and then I'll grab the other one too
Whoa
Well, there's the hiding hold it
Yo, I'm getting jumped too
Whoa
No, no, I'm in a fight. You were the only I'm in a fight
No, no, I'll uh elinor elinor hold it. Hold it elinor shut your trap what you're playing at
I'm literally in the middle of a fake and you're not like telepathic. What's going on?
Oh
Well, actually now's not the time darlin now is not the time
You don't care for the child you're just pretending
You don't even fear
They're such liars. They just want the atom
So
Are you done?
Yes, there are a lot of monsters around
Okay, sorry, um
If you came to miss
All right, sport time to feed the fish head on back to alexander's tank and put those plants in
She was not meant to have a father delta
She was to be an heir to my life's work
And this is where they changed her
Bonding her to you
The child she was died in this room. No
She loves me. She's mine
Right, uh
I'm gonna need to know upset you both. I won't pass you
Okay, we're gonna save
Just
I gotta be for that right I need to stop using gallons and not giving me anything right we have saved
We're gonna pop you away nice and safe and I'm gonna grab your sister that's right behind me right now
Okay, I'm gonna get a little bit trouble. Yeah, we get trouble for it. There's fine. I'll deal with it
And we'll play this diary. Oh, well, we did it
We did it so if the game crashes we know it's because it can't handle a big daddy and a wee sister
Can you attack the mpd, please?
I
Don't want to accidentally hurt him
Oh, no, what the game can't handle a big sister coming in
Oh
This is a problem it seems to be a big sister is causing the game to crash
Oh, is it just odds that she spawns in
Is it just odds that she spawns in when I put a little sister away?
I
Lower the graphics. Okay. I'll lower the graphics and I'll put her in
Oh dear. Oh dear. Oh dear. Oh dear. We're trying we're trying we really are
Right, I'll lower the graphics. I'll pop little sister away
Uh, yeah
Oh
Okay, just be quickly scavenger stuff that's fine and then I'll save as a pop her way
Yep, that's fine. That's fine
She was not meant to have a father
Okay, bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
She was to be an heir to my life's work
An heir to my life's work
Bonding her to you
The child she was right f12. Oh, I forgot about that fucking thing
Right next to me
All right sport time to feed the fish
What am I doing back to alexander's tank and put those plants in oh that did not call on the ball. Are you serious?
It did stop it. You're main
You're getting hacked
bunk
What that didn't work
That didn't work and broke them. Oh, no, I did get one
It's dancing daddy dancing. Oh, she said it. It's dancing
X is eyes X is eyes
X his eyes as in
Hello
Well, I think I have a bumblebee. Would you like a repair? Hi david david the drone. Thank you
Okay, let's try this again copium. I'm going to save
We have saved
I'm going to
Change the graphics to tiny whiny
No, that's the same mode graphic options. Yeah, I was on the right one
Oh, sorry graphics quality. Let's do nice and low apply
Okay
Okay, now that we look like a pancake we are going to save again
Congrats if you didn't save it
And then we're gonna pop you away darlin
And there's going to be no big sister spawn. Okay, and if there is that's okay
Okay
Okay, that's okay that she's sponding because my game will not crash
My game will not crash it's not gonna crash
And my game is not gonna crash
It's not gonna crash
I'm going to see a red big sister. Let's go. Oh wait, hold on. Hold on. Need to get need to get an action shot
Oh, I miss who is she fighting because it's clearly not me
Are you both fighting
Oh, I'm having a
Your little sister restores your health after gathering
Oh, shit. I just fucking activated the wrong one. Are you serious?
Okay, everyone's dying right now
I do not have time to fight NPCs famed me as well. What's going on? Why are you spawning?
Why are you fucking shooting things at me? Are you see is this game serious right now? Why are you fighting me?
Stop, but what are you doing? Fight the sister
That's absolutely annihilate in your arsehole right now. Not me. My god
I I'm getting a blittery
I did not realize how hard big sisters were. Holy shit. Use the flamethrower. Oh wait, this is my link
Did she just run away from me
Hello
You may as well hop on my back now. Jeez. That's all that effort to get you
Why is it keep
You
Am I
Where is she? Hello, is she here?
I think she's still here the music's still
She's still prompted to be here
I
Is she down here
Because I think she jumped down here
Is she stuck in here?
I think she may be stuck in the drop. Yeah, I think she's down stairs and she's stuck in the straw
Hi bubbles
Um, I think she's locked herself down here. I'm about to have a really annoying fight with her
I literally can't even get out behind you you trolling
Is she stuck down here she's not what did she get
Oh
This is bizarre, I don't know where she went. I mean she maybe it's useful it's plausible
I mean the big sister music is still playing that's what my
Uh
How strange bioshock feel an extra wonky doodles
Right so that's where I came out that's fine
Is there anything I can look from here
Sorry about the music being really intense when there's not much happening
I don't really know what I think she's
Be spawned against something. I don't know what she must I think she's in a wall right now to be honest because
Oh
It's just
The game is having a time right now
It was his will to die
To serve the majority by protecting them from his lunacy
Your entire journey is based on your refusal to do this
I'm just gonna put the other sister away right now because she's literally
There's another one that I have to deal with right there. Like I don't know what the game wants from me. I'm so confused right now
Sure, you live forever, but minus your body
I like my body can't save right now feature the idea of my memories and
Personality being stored in the head of some saintly child. Like just one more
I don't know what's going on either random infighting
Like the music is still going like she's here
I'm just gonna save and I'm gonna put this sister away that's on my back right now because
Yeah, there's another one waiting on me. I know I'm not
I know I'm not doing the max amount of adam
But literally if the game the game has just spawned another sister right behind me
Like
She's literally on her own green like I don't know what to do
It's okay
Yeah, let's just
You do have to have oh you have to hack it for
Like that music is big sister, but she's not here so
All right, please no more music and it starts back up again
Okay, I'm just sorry. There's just too many little sisters right off you pop and you go
Oh
You're welcome
Okay
And before like the sisters like over there or something
I'll just be glad to get out of this area because I think this music is gonna permit through the whole thing
Unless she's stuck like in this
Wait
Oh
I know how to get into that room now
Ready gene bank. Jeez the graphics
I will put the graphics back once we move on to the next area just because I don't wanna
Please music, please I'm begging. Give it a rest
I need money. Oh, I've maxed money. Oh, sorry, didn't mean to
Oh
According to I confess
Mother has destroyed dr. Alexander
She tried to slice him into some kind of living saint who would calculate the common good
A bit but
Every time you turn your camera, she's just lurking there
And
Wow
Okay
Oh, we can do a pack of punch, sorry, I'm a courtier forgive me
We put our elder sister through a new regimen of physical and mental conditioning and suited her up with
Drill flip sides recoil
I just want to do damage launch your damage. Yeah fucking damage all the way. Sorry
After that the surface may be our only source
The surface
Yeah, she must have despawned and the game wants to register her
I
Would be scary if it wasn't for the fact the music is bugging out right. Hold on. Let me see because I don't think I've got this far
I think my game broke before that
I cannot recall
I don't know what happens after
I
Oh big thing
You have a favorite
Oh
Okay, we're all about reaching you make sure you do that's fine. Oh it bursts
I've got wits on my side. She says that she's literally on fire
I'm just gonna go written to make shooting if that's okay with you guys
Oh, I did not mean to feel a waste of that but
To complete that game motherfucker
I guess I'm just to shoot them out until all your employees have been
Spent if you will for lack of better words
That girl is on fire
Are you done?
How dare you try to buy me out
Sorry, I know you're monologuing but I need to realize
I feel like such a cheeky shit when I do that
Goddamn you refilling just take me take me
You reel him in now use that console there to take a gene sample
It should print up a genetic key automatically
Gene sample. Oh, yes. I know what button to hit
It tickles
I
Got a genetic you got the key to lambs had uh-huh Eleanor's down there now just head out to the oxyfill station and use it
All right
Okay, and then we're gonna save
And we're gonna leave
The sample disposal button on the panel in front of you would administer a massive jolt of electricity to the tank
More than a kill me
Whatever I may say to dissuade you do not listen
The man whose voice you hear now is long gone
As my mind fades I find my thoughts turn to the suffering that Eleanor will be made to endure
And I don't kill this love
But I can only offer my feeble prayers
Perhaps after my death you can do more
Now please I ask you to grant me peace
You don't want to grant him peace
Isn't that bad leave my boy alone. You don't want to grant him peace is like a big old
Little thing. Did I even have any atom? Oh, I do have 400 atom. Uh, what are you?
Oh, I'm like fully
Kitted out for health and stuff what we doing scenery set the world on fire with this new eruption ability
I've never not killed him. I did grant him peace please. I'm okay. I'll leave everyone. I'm not killing anyone
I say that as if I don't mow down like literally all the splicers. Um
Who didn't celerate?
I want to do this anyway
Oh about an achievement. I don't know what it was because it doesn't pop up
Booth hand
Careful tracker the hacking needle moves slightly so I shrub it
Quiet footsteps on care you take no damage from electricity
You deal more damage when you use electricity. No, I want the fire one
Fire sale you inflict more damage when you use fire. Yeah, I think that's a good one for me
You're all
Price reduced increase bonus to observer
Didn't I not get that I'm like a mental
Oh, shit. I just replaced something. It's not what I wanted. Oh well
Eve's saver plasmas useless. Yeah, like replace that with that one
I think I think I twatted that up, but I tried my best. That's the main thing. Um, yeah
Is gene bank, okay gene bank is what it's gonna be
So
Little sisters gather add them more quickly. Yeah, I'll definitely take that one because that one's really
Elemental storm natural camouflage handyman. Yeah, I don't know why you took that off. Did I give you permission to take off? No, I didn't
keen observer
Uh eve saver drill specialist sports
There's not really anything in particular after that that I need
This keen observer stack with itself
No idea. No idea. Not a scooby-doo
Hello, momo. My god. I could catch him chest out the flint door
Oh
I don't know how to get him
It must
Freaking
You cannot carry anymore. Okay
The more hard deck. Okay. I don't need any of that. Right. Okay. I think we're ready to
Uh, I'll save because I dealt with all the things. I'll actually the overwatch brain raw as soon as I mentioned it now
I'm like, oh my god. I really want to play overwatch with you
Um
So unfortunately, I might be asking you guys. Okay. Wait, can I go back to normal graphics now? I'm gonna go back to normal graphics
Okay, apply
Right, okay, that's much nicer. I think we can all agree. That's much nicer mommy's saving on our own
Please change the ground. I did it. I did it. I did it. I did it. Okay, right. We're done here. Thank you very much. We enjoyed
Our time
Does my hand get extinguished under war? Oh, I just removed your like guns and stuff
Um
I still suspect it was the diary
This is the oxyfill station chief, but don't be fooled by the facade. This is the way in use that key now
Huh
Secret passage
In the wall or secret secret secret secret
passage
Oh, elinor
Forbidden from your daddy. I'm on
I'm in rapture to save you
It's been 10 long long years
And then soon
Be together
Indicate
No, she's not yours. She's mine
I actually want to make an audio where I'm like screaming that you're main basically lost on something
Like proper like onage type thing that you belong to me
I'm
Secret tunnel I'm doing the bioshock 2 remakes through the mountain
It literally goes it's like two lovers forbidden from one another award to face their people
And a mountain debate say I'm surface apart
Okay, new area. We're gonna save because we're in a new area
Swarm out of the mouth type onage. Absolutely
Oh my god
I'd be too scared to live in rapture. I'm too much of a baby. I don't want to be under water
Well, wait a minute. You're a cuttlefish. Yeah, but I still breathe oxygen
Listen up briefly and you belong to me and only wait, why are you spelling it like that feels good
Listen up briefly and you belong to me and only me. No one else you can what I'm saying
That's right. You'd be a good boy. You take it like a good boy. That's right champ
The game is stocking up
Are you doing the dlc today? Oh, no, I don't think I have the dlc
I just don't we'll be camping
This is
I'm trapped in a cage something's wrong. I end up putting you in a cage. What's going on?
Get a little freaky
Scaven
No, I don't know what's up ahead. So I'm getting scared again. I wonder delta
hydration check
Have you any idea what my daughter has given you?
I envy your ignorance
You still believe
The dlc comes with a collection. Oh, maybe I already have it
Sorry, I don't know what's ahead. So now I'm scared again
Oh, there's a pack of punch
Surely it's safe if there's a pack of punch, right?
What we're gonna do? I think I put damage on everything. So maybe shotgun clip size
A double revolver mechanic allows six shots between this machine
Machine gun recoil or maybe you're right. I did that for that
Okay, let's get rid of the recoil because that is a bit atrocious after that
Daddy's
Yeah, but I'm scared as well. So
I
Terrified I don't want to go now because I'm not cocky anymore. There's a bumblebee ahead. I saw the bumblebee
I'm gonna hack bumblebee. So he's mine. Oh my god. I'm actually fucking terrified bumblebee, please be mine
Okay, hi mario. Hi buddy. Do you need healed or anything? No, you're good to go. Hi mario
Oh my god, I'm actually so scared right no, it's fine. I've got the reef one. That's the main thing
Bumblebee is with me as well that helps
I just remember that
Three tons of steel of paternal raves. Okay. I want to see what life was like before rap
I feel like rapture would have been so pretty
Bro, it's too quiet. It's too quiet
This is creepy atrium, right?
One with her no, no, no, no stop
This is so creepy
That's her son elinor lamb no matter what you might be feeling right now. This is business. Huh that cage open. She's coming with us
That's my baby
Oh, she's not well
What the fuck forever in her what the fuck are you doing to her? How did I get out?
Oh
Sorry, there's a
Sorry, I'm a bit of a violent beast
I'm starting to whack in the glass
Eh
What they they're gonna mutate her into a big sister or something
And take heart for you at least bumblebee and ninja step up right now
See
Yep, yep
Yeah, no, this is fine. This is fine. I don't know how the game didn't break either but
Uh-huh, this is fine. This is fine. This is fine. No, seriously fine
Uh-huh, uh-huh. This is fine. I can handle it. I can handle it
Ow, okay. No, it's fine. Please don't back me into a corner
Okay, that's good. That's my task. Thank you. Yep. Please don't back me into a corner
I do not consent
Okay, now quarantine chambers waiting on you get in there. I'm fucking running I guess she's hi darlin
Uh
Look at her delta
Am I still under hypnosis?
Is she still in my head? Do you know why elena brought you here?
She wanted a father
So she found a way to restore you your body and mind
That rebuilt me
And she has been watching you ever since exalting your every act of gospel
Ah if you killed them
The girl lying on that bed
Is no longer my child
Nor my work she is a monster she's my daughter alone
Just as she has always wanted so we went bitch. Let us go
But there is one detail of your mutual bond. She failed your account for what?
Your body was designed to lapse into a coma when her heart ceases to beat
Elena
Uh, I can't do anything
You
Can you give her like a little punch in the chest just to kick start the heart that'd be great
Until the expire I'm not dead yet just in a coma
Father it's me
Eleanor
I'm so sorry mother stopped my heart long enough to sever our bond
Staying near me won't stop you from dying now
Or worse, but I can still help you escape
What this little sister's brought you something that will allow you to take control of her
Eh
Ah, jeez
We fucking missed it. I find that work, but whatever that kind of hurt. I'm gonna lie
God, that's why I look like check the drip
Oh my god, wait what you have taken control of our wee sister. You can now use vents and gather atom
I know this feels a bit strange father, but now you can see through her eyes and tell her where to go
This is how I brought you back without mother catching on
Now first, let's get you out of here. Oh my god. Everything
Everything's beautiful because of my roost tinted glasses
What this is amazing
I hate this is so cool
I'll save when I get out of the vent
Oh my god, that's how they see
There's a way to unlock these chambers she's holding us in find a way to slip in there
Tell me save because it will break
No
I can't save oh well for breaks are breaks. Jeez. Okay. I won't let me save
Oh my god, this is how they see the raptor. They see it beautiful and
They have a shrine to daddy
Oh my goodness
I'm loving this I'm absolutely loving this
Gazillion screenshots, actually me. Why is there so many screenshots of my shop sitting in this folder?
Office of the fear one
Bloodest pales
Attention Augustus Sinclair has been cited within the facility
He will attempt to reach
I would do this part myself
To save your life. I'm going to have to change
To be like you
From here you should be able to locate the pieces of a big sister suit. Please bring them to me
Daddy is so strong
Not gonna I think AC would like this game if it
This is how we see oh my goodness
Why aren't you that fast when I've got you
worse
I suspect Elena of
direct involvement in his return
I fear that to separate them
I'm ready and green to take measures for which I will be
There's a piece of the suit in here father find the rest and bring them back to me. Oh, she's becoming a big sister
Oh
But is she gonna attack
Ten years father
Stuck in this this fever dream
Mother kept me sedated in order to perfect my mind with adam
To her the ideal child is a genius
Serving the common good without questioning it
You have saved me from that
What was that
Mr. Helmut almost
Look everywhere AC or any AC because it's not doing well
I
So I don't get attacked by the ones that are nearby for some reason
Why don't they attack me on my own? I don't understand
The pictures and the statues changed based on your clothes
If you don't attack me, I don't know why they're not attacking me
Or do they only get ravenous when I'm talking about always safe with daddy
Always stay close to a friend
Hey, do you
Do
Big sister went oh my god, I don't know how I'm gonna fight my own freaking daughter
If you were evil this would look much different
Mother was right about one thing
I have been watching you father
Studying the way you have treated others
And now I know who I am
Choice is not cause oh, sorry
Say
Remember that same where I can't read and write but it's like literally my entire job to read and write
I am free
After everything mother has done to me
I am alive and sane enough to be curious about the sun
When you rescued my new sisters
I felt everyone
And it gave me hope for the first time in years
Here you go princess
Okay, she's green
Now I will do the same for all the others
Starting with this one. We're saving the little sisters
And freeing them
Sorry, we have done it father. I'll be there soon
She's gonna see
Not her being mlg pro and she's been in the suit for like five seconds and it took me seven hours to understand the mechanics of the
Fucking game these suits always did make me think of you father
I guess I still remember you in shining armor, but now it's my turn to fight for you
I don't know how much of a fighter I'm gonna be honey bun
Okay, I'm gonna save take this plasmid you can use it to call me to your side in a fight
Bring your daughter to work day summon elinor and our big sister form an overwhelming battle
Wow
Summon the big sister to fight by your side warning nothing lasts forever
Holy moly
Oh, holy moly
Oh, hi darlin
Four first aid kit are we in the boss fight? Why am I getting so many?
Can I reflash? I feel like we're getting right to the end of the game
Let's try out
I don't want to completely rely on her
Sorry, sorry, I I can't aim I assume I can't actually hurt moan door
Subject delta, I know you can hear me. I'm sorry
You have stolen my life's work
And with it my only daughter
But rapture is the house of monsters
The surface will not have us
In our real door have been pranked. We shall be buried as a family
Side by side. I didn't shag you my mom
What the fuck
I'm sorry. You mean the mother much. I was just going to drop this building into the trench. It's miles deep
We have to find Sinclair
Oh, it was that way
Fucking hell elinor Jesus you're starting to scare me darlin. Yeah, yeah
Are you coming in with me?
Yeah, I think I'm longer. I look closer
There you go
Goal complete exit the area. Lam is truly a wolf and sheep stills in sweet home ale amount. No, I didn't mean it like that
Mummy kiss the bear
Oh, you got a sartanical today. You need me to kiss the bearer. Oh, I need to make that pull
I need to make all these plus
Okay
Fucking slow down. You'll be ninja honestly. Why are you on that far? You even went wrong
This is Sinclair's life boat father out the window here. It's our only chance of escape
From what I know of Sinclair. He wouldn't just abandon it
Yes, delta
What of Sinclair
Uh, not the Naruto run. She's out for blood. She has a lot of pent-up anger. She needs a healthy way to vent. She's just venting darlin
Uh, right
This facility hangs over an ocean trench delta. The family has activated timed charges within its foundations
I'm not tamed before detonation. I'm not really tamed. We shall fall and be crushed in the abyss below
Am I really tamed to be honest?
No, okay good. Now that has looked all of Persephone down including the gangway leading to the life boat
I take too long to do. I'm a dilly-dally if I need to. Okay
Uh, right, come on. Wait, what's come on? Let's write
Sure, hint
No hint. Okay. I'll go come on. Oh, there you go
The classmate if you need me father. I'm going to have a look around
I'd rather just have you in
I got an A plus for that. I didn't even do anything. Okay, sorry. Let me let me fucking be calibrated
I'm legit just keeping her out. If she's freaking killin' for me, why would I not keep her out?
You can do health upgrades
I'll send you a postcard from the beach. Ow, what the fuck are you?
Wait, are these guys Philly? Oh, these guys aren't even Philly. Think I'm a Bulbert
I
Sorry, I didn't realize I didn't get those guys really done up
Okay, sorry
Because if she's with you, she's not finding something clear
How did I do that? Oh, excuse me, pardon me. Uh, you? You?
I just buy it out. Just buy it out. Fuck it. I just buy it out. I've got enough money
You can hack that for a vehicle
Am I gonna pop my clothes if I didn't get it in time?
That would have kind of something. I'm gonna lie. I'm kind of stuck if I, you know, spend all that time to get here
and the game's like I perish
But I hear something tingling in. I hear tingling in Eleanor. You need to help me. I'm a bit of a brain
Oh, I was on the I was on the wall. Sorry Eleanor. Sorry. Sorry. Excuse me. Pardon me. Sorry. This suit is a bit bigger than I thought
What save save saving
Mommy's the princess she needs to be carried honestly
One final alpha series ready to die for the family
As Persephone's former owner
He is the ideal man to put you back in your cage
Mother's controlling Sinclair father and he's got the master key catch him
Catch him daddy. Daddy catch him
Can't
Lams in my head
I can't help myself. I have to fight just to talk to me my goddamn tongue
He's making a mockery of you
Ah piss. I heard that
Oh, I've done it now. I'm in awe
Fucking hell Eleanor
Fucking hell both of us are getting annihilated love Eleanor's voice
No
Eleanor come back out right now. Do not leave me alone. I'm gonna cry
Eleanor I'm crying. Please come back
Please Eleanor I'm so scared
I don't want to do this
I'm steaming. Sorry. Excuse me
I hear like I think I hear a bumblebee
Oh my god, this isn't why did I drink so much?
I've been hard man. That's how it is down there. I'm a hard man
Hold on uh, and then bottom
Why he survived these these are big boys
Okay
Sorry
Use the flamethrower, uh, I keep forgetting to do that. Okay, everything looks okay
Nice scavenging. I can I got some
Eleanor
I know you can hear me
I am inside Sinclair's lifeboat now. Is this an enemy delta? I know she's right, but
What's with the Emily? She's screaming right now. She wants to jump in but I'm almost finished. I think we're at the end of the year
We shall return to the surface together
If you know what is this in this game, it's like the daddy's will for your duty. Remember Eleanor
Mummy loves you
Oh, yes
Mother's testing me one last game
Fortunately by now, I'm the world's foremost expert at breaking her rule. Eleanor. Use flamethrower as you do
I'd kiss Sinclair on the lip die for it
Does she not attack if she just had enough
Let's just leave her be then. She's already having a tough enough time
Yeah, I can't carry anyone done
Oh that was Sinclair
Ah
Did he just run at me with fire? Yeah, let's get Sinclair and beat his ass
It seems like this is gonna be the fight
Defeats Sinclair
Kid, I'm sorry. I I've locked you in here
Lamb's making me dance on her goddamn strings. I can't
Stop
You're gonna have to break in here and put me down
Wish there was another way but I'd rather die a man than live like this
You don't want to be a big daddy. What's wrong with being a daddy?
God, he's right father
Mother's betting you'll die in here or that I'll abandon you before the bombs detonate
We can't save Sinclair now. We need that key from him
Find the code to the watch tower or work out a way to draw him out
I tell you the code to that that keypad if I could
It's like lambs put walls up in my head
But the prisoners here might have walked out the number
Check the cells
Please hurry it hurts to keep singing out without say so
Oh, bro, I wasn't gonna attack you but you didn't know
The cells check the cell
Two wait five two five four maybe
Do you mind
Increase the damage, thank you
You cheater. No, we know what it is. That was the code that we had the other time
We came across that code on the teleportation sequence
No
Son, I built this place and I I did rent you out to those plasma trials up at Fontaine
and now
No, I'm paying for it
Wish I had time to make amends
Take the black boat. It's all yours. Just don't leave me like this
That kill him
Can you just stop shooting each other so I can hack you
Wait, I'm confused so let me in or not
I said that for most
I
Think I'll need to heal you though. I can't heal you told me
Let me in
The code is wrong. Oh, it's not the right code. My apologies. Okay
Uh, right. Let let us come in small. Um
We'll do some exploring
Is this a dead end in here
Can I have a light switch, please? Thank you
This is about to me again. That's utterly terrifying. Is this a butterfly?
Eh, mago is a porno, so that doesn't need to tell me nothing, does it?
You got the code
No, no, two six seven three quick
Don't be something with the elemental sponge you get bonus
local
Two six seven three two six seven three two six seven three two
And a six and a seven and a three and a two and six and a seven
And a seven, and a two, and a two, and a six, and a seven, and a eight, and a two, and a six, and a seven, and a seven, and a six, and a seven, and a seven, and a three, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven, and a seven
and a
seven,
a $19.
The
to her daughter, guess she figures they're irredeemable.
Now I got guys clamoring for the next item.
And I want teeth to squeeze any of them, good doctor.
Guess I'm lucky.
You need your parents, don't you, too?
Phineas, there you are.
Why are you telling me on fire, but you won't let me do them.
OK, activate.
Right engaged, ending security curfew.
It's time.
Where are we going?
Oh, we're stuck in here?
What?
There's a few alpha.
Sinclair died a hero of the Rapture family, Delta.
No, he didn't.
Was he a friend to you, or just a tool?
I already repaired Tommy.
OK.
Can you even grasp the difference?
And Eleanor, you have chosen Subject Delta
over your mother, your people, and the duty of your birth.
She may not be your mama, but I sure as hell am your daddy.
I said that wrong, didn't I?
Curfew lifted.
All cell blocks open.
No, I just shot my own freaking drone.
Are you serious?
Yes, I'm special needs.
Mother's turned her attention to the lifeboat.
We must go there, now.
I'm working on it.
I'm working, baby.
Yes, I get the shot.
I get the shot, got it.
All right, here.
I'm going to pick up some stuff, thank you.
Oh, wrong way, wrong way.
Sorry, sorry.
I know where I'm going.
You killed Tommy.
No, I'm sorry, Tommy.
I didn't mean to.
I just have terrible accuracy.
It was, ow.
It's nothing personal.
We're making our way to the ship.
We're going to the ship, and we're making our way,
and we're making our way to the ship.
Oh, no.
Eleanor's going to have freedom.
Oh.
You've got a little fart on your fringe, Mr. Lamb.
They're all in my way.
OK, that'll do, that'll do, that'll do.
I can help.
I like, is this a purple to help?
OK, they're spawning for me to face.
OK, let's save before things go terrible.
I should have created a fart on me instead.
You need repair yet, Tommy?
Oh, no, Tommy lived.
I killed, is it fair or Finney?
Finney is a burp, burp, and Finney.
Finney is a burp, burp, and burp.
Lamb knows the way, do you know the way?
Are we going to make it?
I need a few more shotguns, but can it
give me them the thing?
I respect that.
Something's in my way.
Ooh, something's bugging out.
Ooh, it's all bugging out.
Uh.
I was afraid of this.
Mother has bombed out the ballast compressors, father.
The lifeboat will be too heavy to launch.
Unless, let me think, balance transfer is false.
Balance transfer is false.
Transfer, I'm afraid that I can boil the water
and get the lifeboat to rise.
But I can't generate that much heat alone.
It's time to recruit the rest of mother's little sisters
or taking them with us and head to the pediatric wards.
The pediatric?
Oh, infirmary, right.
This is exactly where we need to go.
Nope, no, it's not.
What?
It's therapy.
You have a multi-part goal.
Press back to go to the Goal tab
and see what part of the goal and switch which one is active.
The arrow on the map will guide you to the active goal.
Oh.
You can't give me two in one.
Just tell me.
Just video games.
Just tell me to go in one direction.
Please, that's all I ask.
Just give me one objective at a time.
Don't give me multiple.
Right, therapy is apparently where the little wings are.
Right, let's go grab.
Follow the arrow.
I'm going to do it.
I thought I was going to be the other one, but it's not.
Oh, yeah, bleh, that hurts.
I won't let her take you from me again, father.
Hold on.
I'm trying.
Papa's trying.
OK, there's a med kit so I can soup.
Oh, no, that was just alcohol.
I don't know why I keep drinking.
Sorry, I seem to have quite a vase with it.
I don't know if it's because of my guy right now.
Actually.
Why is this a horror game?
What the fuck was that?
This is not a server.
What was that?
No insight.
Every word I speak, you already know.
We will be reborn.
Not quite.
Can I hear you?
Oh, shit.
I don't know.
I didn't know she was coming with me for a game.
Mother's people are starting to detonate the charges.
We don't have long.
Oh, shit.
Am I actually under a timer?
I thought I wasn't.
OK, she's beating them up.
I'm sorry.
OK, follow the arrow.
I'm following the arrow.
Follow the arrow.
Arrow, arrow, arrow.
Stop.
No.
I'm following the arrow.
I'm missing all my shots, which is really embarrassing.
Don't work.
I'm following the arrow.
Pediatric ward.
We're almost to the pediatric ward.
Yes.
I expect we'll be fighting our way inside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to be honest.
I expected that too, question mark.
When have I not fought in any part, right?
We'll leave the mentally unwell alone.
I hear footsteps.
But no, baby.
OK, I've already marked them.
OK.
Actually, my second darling.
Push the call button on a window.
Yes, I will.
I will push call button on the window.
Yes.
Thank you.
Call button on window.
Call button.
This.
It isn't safe to begin yet.
We must finish off the splices first.
OK.
Splices first.
There's a lot of noise going on.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I haven't got these guys still yet.
Ah.
Leave.
OK.
Everyone, just calm down.
Everyone, take a moment.
Take a chill pill.
Take a second to collect your thoughts.
Is everyone OK?
Everyone, calm down.
No more Adam to spend.
OK.
Are we satisfied with our little boss fight?
Out you come, pumpkin splices.
God, that's a lot.
I'll wake the children up.
They're stronger than they know.
I should be able to boil off the water
and get us all out of here.
OK.
She's going to deal with them this time.
Go ahead, father.
I'll free them as quickly as I can,
just as you showed me.
OK.
Yes.
Why not let them faint out?
Why not let them faint out instead of just faint?
Aw, OK.
That's so wholesome.
That's actually so wholesome.
What the heck?
I didn't expect that.
That's so sweet.
Oh, my God.
I didn't expect that at all.
Like, what the heck?
This game got me feeling stuff.
You're literally invisible.
Invisibly an attack.
I'm trying, baby cake.
Don't let your dad kick a little bit, OK?
I'm trying.
I maybe need to buy some almonds.
Speaking of leading boats.
Thank you.
That was your gift to her, Delta.
Just as she hoped.
You must be very proud.
Yes, this is pro pro pro pro pro pro pro pro.
It hurts.
Steady father, don't let go now.
I'm not let go.
I'm OK.
Hold it together.
I'm fine.
Water level.
Because you're a terrible doctor and you killed him.
Oh, something's happened.
Hold on.
Let me see.
Meanwhile, people are, I think lime will be a little bit crazy.
Wow.
Oh, I see you.
I literally see that guy back there.
I see him in the quarantine area.
Is it going to like burst out?
Are you going to burst out?
Be honest.
Are you going to burst all over me?
What?
No, that's even creepier.
No, I'm not even interacting with that.
I'm not even interacting with that.
That's even creepier than I could have imagined.
Did you see that?
They purposely made them disappear.
No, fuck off.
You're scaring me.
Did you see that?
I mean, it makes sense they would have over these in the back room.
Hey, you're not the only one with pyro in these parts.
Fuck off.
Is it going to be a little...
Am I going the right way?
Sorry, I'm a bit topsy-turvy right now.
She is daughter to all of us.
No, she's main and you can't have her.
I'm a bit pinned right now, but I think I'll be okay.
Okay, let's use a revolt gun now.
I'm naughty, naughty.
I've not been scavenging as much as I should.
Because I'm running out of bullets.
Animal bullets.
Sorry.
Sorry, I know you're...
Sorry, caught your monologue and just need to buy some bullets first there for the next few fights that are coming up the whole time.
Pack a punch?
No.
I saw that.
What?
Wait, what?
I saw it!
It's fricking doing that to me.
When you've cleared them out, I'll need a signal like before.
Push the call button and I'll proceed.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I find the call button.
The game got me thinking I'm going crazy.
Oh, I love the shotgun.
Did I not upgrade the chambers of the restrict?
I'm not the pickpocket.
Why are you even up there?
I can't even reach you.
How riveting.
You are crazy, but also in denial.
I'm going to kill you.
Don't do that.
That wasn't very nice.
I'm going to need some of these bullets.
Animal bullets.
To see bullets in French, you see in bad.
And to see one shot, one kill in French, you see in bad, in not.
Oh, jeez, you're already here.
God, give me a heart attack, darling.
You're really good at doing that.
You know that, right?
Ring, ring.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going in one.
Animal bullets.
Maybe this will work.
Okay, we have plenty on this one.
Is that what'll make her...
Yeah, it was.
Spread.
You are damning them.
Sorry, I think I might have taken the wrong turn.
I don't...
It's a docking platform.
I don't do anything.
Beautiful music.
I like my bullets.
I'm following the arrow like a good girl.
I'm good at following arrows.
I'm following the arrow.
Why is that?
She's like going all around my head.
Okay, okay.
Is there army?
I don't know.
Are they really at heat like that?
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, okay.
You're for it.
Move back.
And feed her to a world without hope.
Yeah.
Though Utopia may die with her.
I would sooner see her...
Some Utopia raptor is he, John.
Mother will be waiting for you.
Here they come, father.
Hold them off until I can bring it to a boil.
Hey, John.
I got him.
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
Animal bullets.
Actually, why...
I don't know why they all act in like this place.
It's like all lovely and stuff.
Aren't people stabbing each other in needles
to try and get a little hint of Adam?
Like...
Nearly boiling.
I'm working on it.
I'll hold them off.
You just keep doing your thing, darling.
You're doing great.
Keep it up.
You are doing fantastic.
And I'm not male distressed at all.
Animal bullets.
We're doing fine.
It's okay.
I heard a noise behind me, but I guess that's no harm.
Oh.
You don't have to tell me too much.
I can help you fight back now.
Use the plasma.
Oh.
You don't have to tell me twice to use the plasma.
Do you, Joakim?
Hold on.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Okay.
Is she in?
She's in.
Right, okay.
Swap to the fire.
Oh, it's him.
Increase damage.
That's what I want to see, baby.
Okay.
Is there more to these guys?
Or is that everyone?
No, there's more.
Jeez.
I really did not investigate those guys much at all.
Ow.
Fucking hell.
How many others are you?
Relax.
Oh, shit.
Who did that?
That was a terrible attempt at an attack.
How was that?
Sorry.
I'm just trying to, like, variety how I'm killing them all.
Because I've not exactly got them fucking much gray.
I'm getting, like, A pluses for them, but...
Who?
Okay, I'll just let Elinor deal with the rest.
So, there's so many of these guys.
How are they not fully leveled up?
What is blue?
Uh, I mean...
Okay.
Elinor, darling, I'm gonna need you to clutch up, like, right now,
because I suck at it.
Ugh.
I mean, at least they're dropping now.
Please stop spraying fire at me.
Bro, I cannot take any more photos of these guys.
This is getting ridiculous.
Okay.
Yes.
Well, you aren't escaping anytime soon if you're stuck behind that.
I mean, release the docking mechanism.
I'm docking so hard right now.
I'm releasing the mechanism.
Any docking mechanism.
This?
Is this what you mean?
What?
What glass tubes?
These?
Oh, I see it. I see it. Hold on. Hold on. Okay. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm just getting
a blood raid. I don't know. I had the right idea. Okay. I had the right idea. I had the
right idea. It's fine. It's fine. I had the right idea. I got confused. Have we? Elevator
where? Okay. Show me that. Okay. I can breathe under wars. This is fine. I don't have to fight
anymore. This is a good news. I'm going to the elevator. Early, early elevator. The docking
tunnel. Yeah, you're getting reborn again. Hi. You ready, pumpkin pie? Oh, I got a sheep in.
I think you're a bit more agile than I am. Oh, I just got shivers. Oh, pest. Did you get
out? Did she at least get out? I hope she got out. Oh. That's the end of rapture. She
is on my rapture in the bottom of the sea.
Oh, she said look at me while you die. Oh my God, Eleanor. Oh, wait. No, she gave her
a rebreather. My bad. Sorry. She gave her a rebreather. Apologies. I thought she said
look at me while you die. Sorry. Eleanor, why did you save Mrs. Lam as if she didn't just
send them like 10,000 souls and I'm blessed. The rapture dream is over, but in waking, I
am reborn. This world is not ready for me, yet here I am. It would be so easy to misjudge
them. You are my conscience, father, and I need you to guide me. Don't don't do it. Don't do it. Ow. Ow. Oh, wait. I'm
going to sit. I'm going to be like in the back of her mind. I put my clothes on. Shit, I did die. Fuck.
Oh, that was worth it, though. Eleanor's life. That was worth. Real untrue. It was worth.
You will always be with me now, father. Your memories. Your drives. And when I need you,
you'll be there on my shoulder whispering. Okay, that's nice. Oh.
Oh, there we go. Oh, there's the pumpkin spaces that we saved. Oh, hi, little pumpkins.
Yes, I'm afraid my body's a bit broken at the moment.
But I did try my best.
You put me to see. Aw. If utopia is not a place, but a people, then we must choose carefully.
Yeah. But a world is about to change. And in our story, rapture was just the beginning.
Yeah. Wait, what? I mean, I guess it was infinite, but wait, there's more. There's more to the tale
of rapture, even though in what? Is that a good ending? There's always lightest, and then we go
into the gaspar in the sky. You didn't die once during the entire game. Did I know? I thought I
did. Rapture part two DLC time. Is there an after credits? You're telling me. You're telling me.
Good job, mommy, I'm finishing it. We did it. Plot, plot, plot, plot, plot, plot, plot, plot, plot.
Oh, we did it. Oh, my little pumpkin spaces got to go on.
Sometimes I don't mind games that have a greater sacrifice thing behind it. You know,
like, what's Daddy's job? Well, Daddy's job is to protect, and we helped protect and free from
the curse of Adam for the girl. Math 1618, thank you for the gifted membership. Congrats to those
who caught them with your face. Thank you. Thank you very much. Did Daddy ever even exist though?
Wait, what? Am I having a schizophrenic episode? Is that not what the game was about?
All their show and concept are. Oh, my God. They copied me because I did my exposing
viewers stream. I'm teasing, by the way. Did you like the game? I did. I'm interested in what
Infinite is then, because Rapture, if I follow the plot along appropriately, I didn't Rapture
literally just Ka'Blamo. If you play Infinite, you play the DLC on Infinite as well, you should
watch the art books. Play the DLC. It's called Minerva's Den. How long is it? Just like my Pintas.
Mummy Protect, Mummy Attack, but more importantly, Mummy Stack.
Infinite is not Bioshock 3. Oh, it doesn't work. Wait, Bioshock 2 is the end of that plot line?
Okay. No, Rapture's still there? Wait, so she only blew up Fontaine?
It's the bet. My Hot Tiggs, Infinite is the bit meant to, was the best.
What? Four to eight hours long for the DLC? That's the whole last game.
Or did I misunderstand? No, it takes two to three hours, okay. Minerva's Den is five hours.
Infinite wasn't like it. Infinite is another storyline, okay.
I'm sorry about what you gave me a hard time. Remember when old games had long DLCs or good old
days? It's one of the best DLCs you'll ever play though. I think the timeline is infinite.
Infinite is prequel?
Infinite is more fast-paced on play.
Arrap! Arrap!
Someone said you get help on supplies, so I don't have to scavenge too much in Infinite.
Don't play Infinite on max difficulty. I mean, I played this one legendary and I did fine, so I don't
see why not. Infinite is a polarizing game. I'm going to be honest, I do not know what polarizing
means in this context. I personally enjoyed Infinite, but you can only turn your brain off
because the story is really nonsensical. The director from Bioshock wanted to do a thing like
Final Fantasy. He wanted to make everything a different game with no connection. Bioshock too
wasn't made by him. He's a top pro gamer. And usually means it's fun to see what you think of it.
It means you love or you hate it. Oh, I wouldn't have even used that like that. Oh, thank you.
I have learned a new word in the context that you've used it. It means a shit. Okay, I can see where
I bit. Bye. Thank you for the extended membership. Good job. Well, my lovely, lovely Terry.
Bioshock Infinite ended the franchise. Oh, so like, there's no more IPs. They were like,
we're done. We don't care. We're done so. Oh my god, it's the plans.
Feels like the gameplay was a setback from two. So do we call you father now?
I think I prefer mummy over daddy. I'm not sure daddy is.
There's a rumor of another, but the studio
perished. They're supposed to be making it. I think one in two needs a remaster.
I'm going to play Infinite and we might play Bioshock one again.
I think it's a one sitting game. I can't remember. It's been a hot click.
Bioshock Infinite was okay, but it's pretty different tone compared to the other games.
So don't go into a big mummy now. Wait, why am I big? Because I'm pregnant?
I'm not pregnant with Gen 2 yet.
Broly legend. Thank you for this picture.
Oh, big mummy instead of big daddy. Got it. Thomas. Thomas. Are you squidding me right now?
I'm big mummy. Yeah, big fat arse. Mummy ready to sit on your face with that.
Puck Puck. Thank you for the extended membership. Gigi, daddy. Oh yeah.
There is a new Bioshock game being made right now.
They showed photos a few months ago. It takes place in the attic.
Play the DLC for Bioshock 2. It's better than Infinite.
Okay. Okay. Thank you, Blaze. If we're going to strap in, can I go get a cooler?
I may need to play Infinite so I can walk you through the game. Thank you.
Your sacrifice is unironically so appreciated because my dumb ass can't figure that stuff out.
Bioshock Infinite DLC runs out in the story. Sipping in and strapping on.
Mummy had told you I am 162 centimeters tall, which I believe is 5'2 in American units.
Don't make fun of me. I actually thought I was a regular height. Apparently I'm not.
Apparently I'm tiny. Why isn't the cooler in the room right now? It's a refrigerator.
Did she say strap in to strap on? Either way, you're getting it because
I might be ordering the attachment that lets me take photos with the figurine attached to me.
Oh, you want me to get a mini fridge? Mummy is portable. Head fat.
Just the right size to lie on my chest. My heart beat. Oh, that was so awesome.
High five, three, close to five, four. Oh, okay. Okay.
I told you I'm 172 centimeters. Are you squiddin' me right now?
A recon crusader. Thank you for the extended membership. Don't worry,
strongy. You're only like four inches below regular height or a little shorty. You know what
else is four inches? One of these. Do you want oppies, Mummy? Do you think you could lift me?
Actually, I've not weighed myself. I should post a picture of myself and be like,
by the way, this is so much I weigh. Didn't you say you're 153? I'm like pretty sure, Mum.
I'm not fucking with myself right now.
Probably. I mean, I might be 160. Oh, you've got me confused now. I don't know.
Talk, Mummy, once in a while. Tell us the weight so we can train to carry you with one arm.
I'll need to go. You're very low. I'm not. I'm actually heavy. I'm not kidding. I'm heavy.
You wouldn't. So the way fat stores in my body is on the gluteus maximus and around the thigh.
Wait, that's a muscle. No, around the derriere and around the thighs. So when I weigh myself,
and I'll tell you how much I weigh, but I think everyone's going to be surprised by how heavy
I am. I'm like heavy. I'm not, I'm not like a, I'm not a stick. I'm heavy. I just mean there's
an easier center of gravity on the trunk. Um, it's because of our gap. Actually, I think I might have
in the cupboard. Right, I'll see if there's a cutscene. If not, we're going to quickly get a
column. We'll play the DLC if I have it. Are you squiddin' me right now? Aw.
Thank you, Stephen. Bucknick for the super chat. He, like 200, I don't know. Wait, is it extra?
Downloadable content. Play downloaded content.
Wait, there's two? Protectors, Trials and Minerva's Den.
I want to know. Right, hold on. Right, I'm going to go get a column. I'm going to see if I can go
weigh myself, but um, basically look at the alt. Tell you what, I'll make you a deal. Go on the alt
Twitter. Guess how much, how heavy you think I am in LBs, okay? In LBs. You have to do it in pounds.
Because we, well, I use stones. See, we use stones as the British, the British people
use stone, okay? So go come up with a number you think I weigh, and I'll go weigh myself in a
second, okay? I'll go get a cola as well, so give me a hot, hot second.
Right, I'm going to go convert it, and then I'll tape it. Oh no, I can't fucking tape it,
shit. Because I'm not signed in. I'm like, yeah, damn. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. I need to convert it. I need to convert it. Hold on. Oh, shit. No, it must be that way.
Hold on. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Right.
What are the units? And then what's that in stone?
Sorry, I'm going to say all three units. You're fucking welcome, by the way.
I'm converting everything for you. Okay. Now, if you, right, let's see what you're guessing.
Ooh, ooh. Right, you're, ooh, someone got close. Someone got really close.
Okay, I'm going to say all the units. You can tape it. I can't tape it to you,
because I'm not signed in on my YouTube account. Okay, you ready? I turn up. 56 kilograms,
123 pounds, or 8.7 stone. And it's all in my derriere.
So, there you go. You guessed it. You are not heavy. Oh my, I think I'm heavy for my height, though.
I'm one off. Let's go. That's not heavy. Oh, is it? Am I being dumb?
It's Johnny's 9% ass. Wait, I thought for my height chart. Wait, BMI scale. Let me look into
that BMI scale real quick. BMI scale, NHS. Give me that obesity. I don't know if maybe because
of my height, it, it, like, acts like I'm, like, mega fucking obese. I was like, fucking relax,
she's okay. That's light? Is that? Okay, what do I need to start now?
Yes, I'm over 18. What the fuck, right? 163 kilograms. I'm 56.5. Why is that asking kilograms
on the fucking NHS? Wait, it's asking if I'm weight? It says, are you Middle Eastern? Sorry.
Sure. Sure. I'm a white pancake. What are you going to do about it? Oh, I'm in the healthy category.
Okay. My BMI is 21.1. BMI is unscientific. Your weight? I'm sorry you had to find out this way,
that I am paler than glass of milk. Yeah, that figures. There you go.
We can carry you bridal style with these.
Are you squiddin' me right now? I was so cute.
Thank you, the bitty lord, and thank you, Bleeding Reflinge 75. Why would we jump
at the same year? BMI has usefulness for population, but not for individuals. Yeah,
I think if you're a bodybuilder, it completely messes you up. No chocolate mummy. I was,
I was heehawin' watchin' Azur's, eh Azur's, watchin' Sheeby's stream. So, I spoke to Sheeby
about this, and I was like, we at Vila, if you will, have accidentally stumbled into the most
diverse fucking team imaginable. You can't make it up. You honestly can't. I promise you,
fucking, do I, do I give a rat's fucking arse about meeting fucking quotas of variation
between folk? Do I give a fuck? No I don't. And I ended up with like the most diverse, like
gen mates, diverse team to work with, and all that jazz, like it's quite funny. I mean, I think
it's funny, okay? Yeah, you're like a proper kid, with that weight, you can print, so I was carrying
the whole day. Eh, anyone with any real muscle masters BMI at the window, no such thing as a
brickie with a healthy BMI? Yeah, no. A Latina for gen two? Will she better apply? I'm fucking waiting.
I wanna hear, I wanna hear the stun, I wanna hear, I wanna hear her go stronny when she says
my name. Yeah, yeah? Oh, you won't. Latina, come to me. I summon you Latina. Come to Vila.
That's terrible, but also hilarious, equally. Shibi says we need a Latino. I mean, I need a little
spicy girl to teach me some Espanol toast. We need that. I think accent is definitely gonna be a bit
more desired. We need a bit of variation, you know? We've got our, we've got our Yopnik accent,
we've got, well, me, but I don't count. We've got Azura's absolutely fantastic voice,
Mercy's fantastic, Amy's fantastic, Shibi's fantastic. So, if and when gen two do get confirmed,
now don't shoot the messenger, I'm just here for a good time. I'm just here to fucking jerk off later
and post it, you know? An Asian Latina and in the Middle East. I have terrible news, if you're
wanting an Arabic girl, what we participate in is called Haram, and she will be stoned to death
by her family. So, no, we are not gonna be fucking participating in any of that shit. No, if you're
fucking Muslim, love you, but Jesus Christ knows that this is the most Haram against your religion
tape shit. Please do not touch us at the 10-foot pole, okay? Because holy fuck, you're gonna get an
eyelid. Yeah, I ain't fucking touching that shit. I ain't touching that shit. I'm saving you. I'm
doing you, inshallah, I'm doing you a favor, okay? Wallah will not allow it, okay? I prefer a live
girl as myself, okay? I am Haram, yes you are, but I could not recruit a girl non-full while she is
you know, really, has religious ties, in that sense. Because holy fuck, I'd rather keep you alive
around your family, that sort of thing. The link on the alt-twitter is broken already? Oh, right, I'm
gonna buy members, I'm gonna buy Elon Musk, you win. I'm buying premiums, so I can upload videos,
and I'm gonna do that thing where Emmy linked with other stuff. I don't know how she did it,
I'm just gonna copy and paste what she did, because she's smart, okay? Can we just get a veal
asset for you all then? I mean, Azur is probably the one who'd probably end up with a veal asset,
just debate her father, surely he'll come around, absolutely not. Wait, how much do you weigh? I
weigh 123 pounds, 56 kilograms, or 8.7 stone. Enjoy. If you need motivation for any lifting
bros, not yourself. After you said you're height and weight, I can confidently say putting you
in a standing full Nelson would be easy for me. I didn't comprehend what you were communicating
there, okay, I get it now. I said 125, well, you got a good guess, man. 8.7 stoneys? Why would you
just say like over 20 LBs in that, literally, I can lift one there? I can't believe it,
how does the architect end up with so many lift bros? I mean, I can motivate you though,
don't think I won't. Okay, so for the DLC, am I doing protectors trials? Because that just
sounds like an endless wave type of thing, which isn't quite for me. Minerva's den, sounds good to
me. Bro, I just don't doubt how much. Okay, I wish I could pin it. 56 kilograms, 123 pounds,
or 8.7 stone. And then go on the alt Twitter and tell me where all that weight is. That's right,
I'm getting my ego stroked because I'm stroking myself. Stop, stop, I'm excited, okay, I'm
all really, and I'm having a good time, I'm having a lot of fun playing with you. Okay, I'm getting
a bit excited. Protector trials is not worth it. Okay, right, you heard it here first, Minerva's den,
and we go. Oh, DLC time, DLC time. But steel is heavier than feathers.
Rapture, central computing, start Minerva's den, select a difficulty, I'm new to shooters.
Are we getting a test at the end of the stream? Yeah, sure. 120 lb is ass and the rest is my body,
that's funny. Please don't copyright, oh, please don't copyright. Okay, it's late, rest well, sleep
well. Hey, apparently I'm fanboy height. Liar, you little cod gamer you. 1968 Rapture,
are we gonna get nice Rapture? Are we gonna finally see a knife?
Minerva's den. Subject to Sigma is approaching Minerva's den.
Oh, no. Wait, what?
Sorry, I'm too much of a brain, what? I just see Sigma on my brain, it's like, I see Sigma.
Sometime later. Okay, rest well, don't sleep, goodnight kiss, sleep well. Sweet dream.
Uh, what the Sigma?
Get that starfish off of me, I gotta go take a shower, I need to shower to Agile.
I was like, should have put deodorant on, I'm like, now it's too late.
Okay, so we're a daddy.
Okay.
Hello, Mr. Sigma. Oh, no, my name's actually Sigma. The name's Porter.
Oh, Dr. Tenenbaum tells me you're here to help us get the thinker out of Rapture.
I'm actually called Sigma, but nothing worth doing ever is.
You should be able to get inside through an airlock.
I'm actually called Sigma.
Yeah, the ad.
Is there more secret sea slug?
Secret sea slug.
Or accurate, is it absolute Sigma grain set?
What's that, you thought the streamer would go offline after completing the game?
No, I built the DLC because I'm on that Sigma grain set.
Amen.
I'm stuck. Oh, God, sorry, I'm stuck.
Uh, I assume it's the same mechanic. I just don't have a wean.
Is there anything here that I need to spot before I jump in?
No.
Dr. Stony Sigma, I'm so sorry, but you've been diagnosed with Sigma.
I'm just gonna have to suffer this.
Sorry, I am very happy right now.
I, like, I feel accomplished. I figured out the game, I completed it,
and we're doing the DLC together and never just get to chill out at the same time.
I only have telekinesis and drill.
Okay.
So we're starting with nothing, which is okay. We're allowed to start with nothing.
What's that?
You've been done half a movement, half a decent.
I'm rather scared. I don't like the ambience. I want to feel underpowered again.
I congratulate you on the founding of Rapture Central Computing.
The Great Chain only grows stronger with each pair of hands laid upon it.
What?
I trust that you and I will choose to pull Rapture in the same direction.
I am rather scared. I'm not. I don't feel strong anymore. I don't feel empowered.
I'm actually really pretty scared right now.
Right, so there are, right, I don't have a camera, so I can't, like, level up.
Oh, it's a robot. I ain't doing math. It took me long enough to...
Uh, I guess we just go wherever.
What steps into Minerva's den?
Me?
Or there's no a story?
Yeah.
What's the thinker for himself?
But you see, old friend, the machine has chosen me.
Okay, I guess we can die sometimes at a save station.
Let me just save real quick.
property of read well main
So I can only melee right now?
He can't.
Read wall. He and I founded Rapture Central computing together,
but the greedy bastard pushed me out years ago.
Splicers, the security. He pulls the strings in Minerva's den now.
Oh.
Hi, Stronny. I haven't been a fan for very long, so in catching up on all your videos and Patreon
audios, your grooming audio has to be your best one. Never thought my tentacle would react to a
Scottish last term need to appear in the audience.
I'm not sure.
I'm so sorry. That sentence is so wildly inappropriate, but it's hilarious.
Thank you, Anon, for the tip.
Literally, your grooming audio is the best one yet, for fuck's sake.
For anyone who hasn't consumed it, one, relax. It's me. Two, relax. Okay, that's absolutely hilarious.
Well, you like me calling you an idiot while like violently writing you?
I can do more of that. That is what your tentacle is going on.
But thank you for the tip, Anon. It's absolutely hilarious.
A laser?
Okay.
Please, yeah.
You fucking idiot. Just beat me all right, fuck.
I don't know what I'm doing after this stream.
I don't know what I should say.
Because normally I go like super non-verbal.
I don't know how I managed to muster up the ability to speak at the end of the...
Whoa, stop, stop. You're scaring me.
What?
Ah, what the heck, man?
What? Wait, was that the one I was supposed to do?
Are you trying to bring us with you when you go?
I don't... Wait, is that the one with the ability to use fake gaming?
Are you squiddling me right now?
And now it's your turn.
That's why I keep getting save stations.
You're gonna make me scared.
Thank you, tiny spainy. I'm coming for you.
One second, I need a fart on her.
That was really loud. That was going to pick up on me.
Sorry, I'm all scared again.
I'm all scared again because I'm not, um...
That was too early.
I'm all scared again because I'm not strong.
Mr. Ryan hired me to build a computer that could keep an entire city running on time.
The Rapture Operational Data Interpreter Network.
Folks call it the thinker for sure.
Oh, the spear key to come R-word you. Sorry, got it, got it, got it.
Sorry, I thought you meant actually N-game key.
I was like, uh, the spear key to come get you. Sorry!
Another reasoning processor it may finally think for itself if Duran could see me now.
So, there are little sisters in this room?
Tenning Bomb can provide you with a bonus Sonic if you complete the protector trails.
Complete all the trails then return to the garden.
Okay, so I...
Those vacuum bots sucked up all sorts of things before they went on the fritz.
Crack one open and you might find something you can use.
Sorry, I'm...
Hmm? Excuse me?
I can hear him slamming around over there.
Are you squidding me right now? Sorry, this is freaking out.
Mama, I really liked your SPH audio the most.
I don't want to be too selfish, but another one of those would be really nice.
You are really good at being mean to us briefly.
I don't think it's so hard to be mean.
No, I don't want to explore into the enemy.
I mean, I can definitely make another one, but I don't mean...
That felt really mean, but I mean, shit, if you enjoyed the mission completely.
What would they do if I did another PPT anyone?
I can hear someone walking around, unless it's my squelching feet.
Then...
No.
We feelings like the T's then? I did feel it was me.
But if you like it, then it's different, you know?
The thinker knows you're not the thinker.
I hear a squishing around, but I'm starting to think it's Mafia here.
Okay, it's my squishing around down here.
Oh, my amazigh!
OK, I'm just curious just what the fuck I'm doing here.
okay that hack tool should come in handy head back up to my office head back up to
my office I am both of them
oh no our chat's frozen wait is it better not be
wait what happened
are we good you're making me pan do you mean audio then do aftercare
server and feels better yeah that's probably just on screen
this is my nervous day I have to agree with that last tipper
strony sometimes gives me sundry vibes strony gave her fans the tools to groom
her girls but left herself out on purpose keeping her reflames guessing
Ali what I get satisfaction from is like fulfilling your fantasy that's what
gives me the ultimate satisfaction like not being weird about it but I do
genuinely like it thank you darling gale Tia and a anonymous for the tips I
definitely have like the satisfaction that you're satisfied I'm like oh yeah
yeah I cooked here you know can we get gas later oh you're not tingling right
now oh you didn't just tingle there how do you do gasoline ASMR that doesn't
make any sense I love the name of the enemy being the
thinker what if I do the other people's fancy I just like it that way cuz it's
like and you're getting what you want I'd rather not guess on what you want and
I'd rather give you what you want you know because I get more satisfaction when
you guys are like I literally cannot feel my legs after listening to that last
audio like that
that
well splicers haven't gotten into my office thanks to the thinker's security
I'm giving you top-level access now all right isn't that just a scam thinker more
like the stinker am I right boys oh wait wait hold on let me give a sunboard up
the thing or more like the stinker hold on it shy give a second give him a
second give him a second he's shy okay the thing or more like the stinker thank
you thank you and the crowd goes well hard and the crowd grimaces and we're
happy when mama is happy mama is happy when we're happy it's a perpetual
circle and I'm damned proud to be a part of it
don't fell down that first year in London working for
Oh
Hardly
Sorry, I almost picked up my call-offs
No, leave my robot alone. Why don't you just fly up bumblebee? I have to admit
You're being rather silly right now bumblebee
He was a brilliant engineer
We saw eye-to-eye once long ago, but the splicing made him paranoid
Delusional he'd murder us both to keep the thinker here
All right, come on bumblebee. We've got some baddies to kill
Strongest really wave material
Shit's way
Unless inking makes up for it press stand up. Yeah
Something's going on over there
Puppy thinks she has all the power here well, she does it's over boys
I would say save yourselves, but it's probably already too late for you to
Thank you the very Lord oh
So I do have the power wait, I like that. No, no keep talking. I like that
Quick save quick save I'm quick saving. Why is there a fight about to happen?
I've got him so nervous. I don't know what comes of the head search containers for loot. I mean I'm flying
I'm just not very good at it. Wait, did I complete a challenge or no, sorry, I'll figure out I
Don't need saving. I love it here
Is I just here sorry my smell just go wait off my face so fast when I heard that daddy
I'm not really the parish daddy
The Lancer is the most technically advanced big daddy that rapture ever produced
Between you and the little sisters, and if there's anywhere that you
Can I just sunlock him, please so he doesn't hit me at all. I think he's even a bumblebee, you know that
I
Fucking mail in each other today. Ow. Hold on
Ow
No, no, I don't have any ammo. I don't want to waste my laser beam on them
A little sister can I be saved?
This one is my savior if I accidentally start a road
I don't want to play this game mechanic anymore
Like I
Know I know this is the core mechanic
But I'd rather produce the all audio right now
I
Don't you make an audio of you hypnotizing us into thinking we can't move our bodies
Kinda like sleep paralysis I would love to see what an obsessed straw me cuddles looks like I'm talking mercy levels of obsessed
I hold on hold on my inbox in shape, then you mind me
I literally
This is not going well
I
Never talk about expensive gasoline ever again, you still got telekinesis. Do you need to eat yet?
Right, all right, let me push up
Why don't you make an audio of you hypnotizing us to thinking we can't move our bodies like I would love to see what an
Obsessed Johnny Cuddles looks like with me
Is that
Is that wholesome or is that I get to do wherever I want to you type of audio
What one is that anonymous you didn't specify?
And everyone just said the money capacity
I'm also thinking it's the enemy watch along safe. Can she read for four hours? Oh
Wait Danny to oh and I've even thought about that
Or is it dubs or subs are we doing for the enemy watch along?
I never even thought that far ahead and I just remembered on that side of the community everyone goes absolutely apeshit over the
dubs and subs
It's only in Japanese. Oh, well, there you go. That's the sort then right no one can argue about it
We're doing some subtitles no one can argue
You might struggle with the subtitles
Yes, but is that gonna stop me
Sometimes I have sometimes I have an ability to read or not
It's up to you if you do something to stop. Okay, I think we're doing stuff. Thank goodness
I thought of choosing an enemy. Well, I picked another one. Oh, I've already forgotten the name of it
There's another enemy called like VV something I
I don't know if you guys will be more familiar than than it than me
And no one can argue it you can you underestimate this community
I'll be up to you if you can't find some and just think of them
They're called push being able to read less likely than you think
I don't know if you guys know what anime it is. It's like called like VV something I or something like that. It's really short
It's not too long. Oh
My god, you guys are such weebs. Yes. Oh
VV Florae I song that's it. That's the one that's what I picked for next month if the watch along goes well
You little fucking weebs. I love you. Oh shit. You guys are perfect me like VV. I you know that V tripper
She got her own anime
I got recommended. Mommy, I would submit my mind and surrender my body to you
I mean, if I'm gonna hit most of this audio you might not even
I might just take over your mind. You don't even need to submit, you know what I'm saying? Just let me in
Based off how often you read a comment fully correct
This might be difficult me like confused with the plot like what's cool? Why is the plot suddenly bearing also?
Me right who reads like clothes is some other word which I've already forgotten
My Xbox just turned itself on again Xbox turn on or turn off. I don't know. I can't remember. There used to be a big prank
Have no resistant bros. It's over for us. No, I want to do a break you down
Can I do where I break you?
I've got the forget your name screen coming up soon, so I'll be interested to see how that goes
So any can do whatever she
Xbox twist this much balls. No, we're not twisting bollocks out here, right?
Can I say something controversial and you're gonna hate me for it, okay? I
Thoroughly enjoy this game. I'm loving it
We will possibly return to the DLC in a future stream
and
Strongly fist the reflin a smart more likely than you think says one of my kings. Um, I
Won't do I won't make it. Okay. I won't make it. I want to do it. I wanted to do a four-part series
I'm not sure I'm allowed to make it
and
Yes, I didn't anticipate playing the DLC. So my brain was like over finish the game
You be okay, but we'll come back to the DLC because you guys recommend it. So we'll do our layer day. Okay, and I
Think it was a great game. I really enjoyed it. I enjoyed the game. I enjoyed the story. I enjoyed the lore
I can't believe Eleanor actually saved her mum like her rude as if I didn't just go through hell and earth to you know
Grab her and save her and all that like
Controversial oh sugar. I don't have my password. So I can't redirect
Danny to go and turn my other PC on and redirect into it
No, is it true I might have to
You got the best ending so it's pretty good
She's not logged in literally. I can't fucking do anything
Since you said you wanted to know what we wanted we want a lovey-dovey breeding wife or do you really?
That sounds cute
Whoa, enjoy it whoa hate that third hate that third arm that's embarrassing
Get out of here. Hold on. Let me get rid of that real quick. Oh
my
Studios is crashing
And it's completely broke. Okay, uh gonna be honest
I can't actually move myself or remove the asset because my vTubing studio has crashed
But you can still see me. So that's the good news
So i'm gonna save you save
And then we'll come back
I will pause
And then I'll pause this in hopes that it's gonna fix my vTub studio or I may just
Oh that oh something's happening
Uh
Wow, are you happy to irradiate it stony honestly? It's literally a bug in there
What are you?
Oh
Progress. Hi, I'm gonna use the chat to cover up my
We don't need she's evolving any three arms
It's gone
I'm just so happy to see you
Are you squid mirroring? No, you can't Brian. Don't say that out loud
Poppy is going for a wank and the reeflings will be doing the same
Brian the fact that you said that out loud with so much confidence Brian jesus
Brian gives me shit
Thank you the video lord
Hey for the super chat
Cynthia
Um
I am going to take a rest and reset wait. What's the plan of agenda tomorrow?
Is she beyond? No, she's not
She be cotton bum. It's not online today. This is normally when emi would go up but emi's just going on
Sorry, I'm just analyzing is she be coming on
Is she be coming on at nine? Oh, she's coming on in two hours time. Uh, no in one hour's time
Uh, if there's any lurking moderators, can you post the link to she be stream in an hour because I'm locked out in my fucking discord
Hold on let me let me task manager real quick
Oh
Something's happening. Hold on. Oh, what the fuck is that on my screen?
Can you see that on stream as well? Oh you can what the fuck is that? What is that?
Hmm
What is that symbol on my screen? Do you know what that can you see that? Yes, you can see that. What is that?
Huh, I should be because I don't know. I'm concerned as well if I've been banned
Um
It's ink loading. Okay. I'm gonna just leave it and do this thing over there. Oh, is that my ooloo market asset? No
What can he be?
Is that ooloo market asset?
By the way, I have merch at ooloo market
What are you?
Sorry, I'm going to try and identify what it is. Oh
You don't know what it was. It was fuji tech
It was teaser for gen four. Oh my god. You've got me. It's a mountain literally
You're getting hacked prepare for big daddy to arrive. Uh, we're gonna
Should I call you big daddy in the audio? What should I say in this audio?
As I said, normally I get super quiet when I'm recording it like you gotta let them know use code strutty 10% I'll give you some
literally
No, the copy and paste and you got the
The reflans name
You got the reflans name in the message
um
Okay
Yeah, you want me to call you big daddy like unironically though
Put a baby in me big daddy
Get a bit too spicy get a bit too spicy for youtube now. Hold on a minute
Because so when I'm recording I'm like it's super non-verbal just because
You know subspace and all that I'd I very I can't really
Myself and be like, oh, I'm so dominant right now. Like no, no
Oh
I'm probably what I'll do is I'm gonna brain roll up calling us big daddy will fart. Oh hell. Yes the non-verbal is
Um, oh, I need to ask. What do you think about the recording situation?
So I use my 3d o and one side is pointed to me and the other side of the 3d o is pointed to the floor wink wink
Does that make sense?
Do I keep that set up or would you rather like I put the 3d o in front of me or
No, you're happy with the system
You know for someone that finds the way she says daddy cringe a little well, are you gonna breathe me daddy?
You're farting my eating your mother for that
I
Sounded good sounds fine. Whatever's comfy. Yeah, I basically have to lie back on my chair so it balances on my chest a little better
She'd be oriented
Please woman. I got a word clear. Oh, what's wrong daddy? You don't want to play?
This is why you can't give me this is why you cannot tell me the truth because I start pushing the envelope or envelope more and more
You
We can hear your heartbeat in it
How loud are you listening? I didn't hear that heartbeat when I went through
It's because it's placed on my chest, so I guess
Maybe it'll take forever for it. Well, I need to brain roll first. I need to like check out mentally first
Let me bring
Stony wants me to produce nothing but dust crank that volume literally prank. I'm John
So when do you feel send the envelope?
So what I normally do after stream is a brain rot for like an hour. I just clock out. I don't interact with anything
Just pass though. Although I do take a look at marshmallows, too
Um, there's nice me flins that say this stream was really nice even when it was shirt and I'm like
Oh
Um
Frank this little job owner you
I like the heartbeat
Not even
Oh, no, the Emily and Vigo come get a pet off me and all that because they miss me. Um
But they're very independent putters, but when when I open this door, they know that I'm not working anymore
You know, did you ever see that twitch clip where the guy has a dog and he's like, thank you so much everyone for liking and subscribing
But the dog recognized that that meant he's about to go off stream and it got all excited
Do you remember that clip? Basically, that's what Gimli and Vigo are like when I open the door, they know I'm not working anymore
So then they're all
Um
So Joe, but I'm in at this point. Just ink me dry correction
Bratty squid girl one of my cuttlefish
But yes, I'm a cephalopods. So that also looks okay
Go on. I like when I can hear you, but often you're very quiet. I am fucking
And then I get deafened by an explosion or a scream
And an audio or on live stream
Stony another smoothie clip just hit the tube. Oh, no
Oh, no, this can't be
Wonka earth
Hey
Oh for fuck's sake, it's a better body script
Oh my god, the thumbnail says monkey noises
Oh
I think I
um
Well, if you need something to do to keep you occupied between now and she be going live
There's monkey noises has been
Enough
I don't want to listen to it because I'll get copyright off of his thing, but
Oh my god
Oh my god, it's emmy
It's emmy and she be reading the script
That please put some puppies in me why not so hard
I fucking was so surprised. I even got the courage to come out with that
I was completely like non-verbal through that whole thing. Like normally sometimes like I'll say something
I'll be like, oh please or this or that or whatever
My ass
was like
Feeling it. Okay
That's
Another smoothie video has hit the tubes of the world. We're in solo solo
I'm so surprised I managed to even come out with that one
Demon Slayer mit suri konoji cosplay
I'm gonna be doing the cosplay streams now
Get me in boy. Oh, it's this. Oh, right. Okay. Okay. I know who she is
I was like, I don't recognize that character from demon slayer. No, I know who that character is you want a cosplay of that
Okay, now I've just looked up the cosplay of this beautiful anime girl. All right. There's one problem
She has a rack and I don't
Ha
That is my only issue
So I'm gonna have to I will draw the makeup
But yes, I can do cosplay streams if that's what you guys want. I am happy to provide. Okay
I will make it a stream if you would like because I will I would draw in boobs on them
Yeah, you mutter in the line was real the technical felt it. Did I did I make you technical tingle?
Pause play stream
Wait, am I wait am I not allowed to do them because I'm a feature of her or am I allowed to do them?
Because I'm you know, I'm in my own mate
I really want to do Rebecca from cyberpunk ASMR and it would just be like neck down
And then everyone'd be like, oh look at your tummy and I built. Yeah, I got tummy
I got a soft little tummy and go pit-pit-pit-pit-pit and I'm gonna paint myself blue. Oh wait, should I paint myself blue?
I mean, I could paint myself blue. You're allowed to do what you want. Yeah
Sorry, I don't care about the beach everything do it
You're like, yeah, uh, you are actually literally wherever you want and I'm like
Thank you
Pre your post goomba stone. No
Your ass hasn't spoken
And how long and that's the first message you fucking give me is that Rebecca got goomba stone? You're done for wait
You're your tummy. Yeah, you know Rebecca. You know same Rebecca. Hold on. Let me get let me get a picture of her
uh, let me
Let me get a picture of Rebecca
any Rebecca's
Image
Same as
Why does it have a not so far?
She's in a bikini. Wait, that's not Rebecca. That's not her actual
Yeah, she's in a bikini
Why is it so hard to get a reference of a video game character?
That looks like AI because that's not even her design
Long story short, I'm in a bikini and a jacket for the stream. Okay
I'm in a bikini and a jacket for the stream. Is that acceptable?
Hold on. Let me grab this. Oh, no, it's a web. I'm it's a fake link
Fine. Fuck you. I'm screenshotting
That was me. That was my pc because I screenshotted it was having a hissy fit. I don't like when I screenshot
This is what I want to dress up as on stream
I
Like she has twin tails too
Sometime done
I want to dress up like this, but I'm not going to show my face. It's going to be neck down only. All right
You're going to do the body paint. So I've looked into her cosplay before
It comes with a stencil and you just stick it on your on you and then you wet it
So I'll still be able to do it
But yeah, so it's basically jacket and bikini and because rebecca doesn't have a big rack
Yeah, I kind of fit rebecca. You know what I'm saying? So it'd be pretty lower, aren't you?
Like a cadbury cream egg. You know what? Fuck you
Um
Yeah, I thought you meant the other girl with a bob cut. No fucking candy. I don't know
I don't know how anyone is going for lucy. Sorry
Lucy lucy from cyberpunk. You have the choice between rebecca or lucy and people are arguing over lucy
sorry
Sorry, but how is anyone genuinely arguing for lucy? Fuck it
I couldn't give less of a rat ass about lucy's design. It's shite. It's all right, but it's shite, you know
Rebecca calls. That's me
I think they're both okay. You don't think rebecca's a 10 out of 10. I love her though. She's just like me for real
She's literally perfection like this is me bouncing on her now
Lucy's the e-girl that literally ruined david's life. I like rebecca about her first journey. Oh, okay, that's
Actually canceled shipped and departed deeply departed. Uh, it's okay to be wrong reflying. Okay, it's okay to be wrong
You are more autism
Stroney
What was that in response to?
Lucy had a couple of good moments. I'll give her credit where it's due the stretcher scene
Eh, but rebecca goes hard
Glad the studio forgot to keep her
They should have killed lucy not rebecca
Real untrue
Um
I didn't see the anime but from aesthetic wise the crazy eyes on lucy hit different. Yeah. Um, so as I said, I wouldn't do
I won't show my face
I'll do like neck down ASMR stream
And I'll wear the wig and everything. I mean, sorry my real blue hair
My real blue rebecca here
and
She just had to sit to sit. She did
rebecca
Stroney, please be the e-girl that ruins my life pop up up get main broken
You can never ink to someone else again. I will never feel like good. It only feels good with when it's me
That's terrible. I shouldn't do that about the same time
kind of hot though
Blue wake over your real watermelon colored hair exactly my real green and
Here's the reason rebecca is flat girl confirmed. I accept your offer stroney
Is it gonna be for patreon member? No, just just a regular smagular stream. I like rebecca
I wouldn't pay all that
I was dressing up and painting myself
Blue
I might have to wear a body suit actually now that I think about it. There's no way I can stream with paint on me
Can you get paint that sets on the skin?
If you can get paint that can set on the skin, I will paint the fuck out of myself
Got it only ink to you
Stroney really are the perfect woman. What because I'm weak enough
Give us the adam smasher treatment
Oh
Oh my god
The same day I do the rebecca stream. I will do an alternative audio as well. Yeah, body paint this body paint
Does body paint stay on
That sounds so dumb unlike body paint is temporary
But like does it stay on so i'm not gonna get my 3d or covered in blue paint? That's what i'm trying to ask
I mean you guys might know better than me
Uh body suit would be easier to go with. Yes, it's on server. It's a lifestyle choice
We've we flings one. I hope so. I hope you always win with me
Rebecca's ass is like 10% of what you have on me. How can you call me?
Rebecca's the best
Wait, hold on. Rebecca
Rebecca voicelines
She's cyberpunk. I don't know if I can mimic her voice. I doubt it, but
I'm so clumsy. Sorry
Sorry about that handsome. It's no problem sweetheart make it up to you next time k make it up to you next time k
I love Rebecca
Bumbo voicing that was good
Sensitive, you know, why are you yelling at me? I'm sensitive, you know
Triple Rebecca. I love her
I'm Rebecca. I'm Rebecca joining up with main's crew. I hear you're joining up with main's crew
Cheers
We've seen you around man. We've seen you around us. Buh-bye. David my man. What's going on?
David my man. What's going on? I fucking love Rebecca. Did I tell you how much I love Rebecca? Anyway, just a bit of a rasp
I can only artificially fit the rasp. Well, I'm not gonna gonna. Yeah, you'll like that. Yeah
Rip Vod. No, no, no, this isn't copyright
It's cause it's mashed together scenes and I'm talking over it if it does get copyright you get another free audio
That's how we're doing it right
Um
Hi strongy. Thank you for the stream today. Yeah, but you're welcome. Thank you for also being such a good cuddle pop
Oh, that's such a cute combination. I think strongy likes you or dare
Oh, that's how i'm gonna get a natural rest or dare
There you go
Uh, what will you do today call his big daddy?
Oh
Since you're ovulating today, maybe
I can't read the rest of that
The vocal for a wild card the only vocal fry we accept around these parts is a wild card
Okay
Talking about Becca, I'm excited for the jada figure that is gonna be around jada. Who's jada?
Hold on. I'm like literally researching jada figure
What's jada?
Hmm
Oh dear
Marshmallows. Yeah, I'm looking at marshmallows. I'm not allowed to look at marshmallows
Check out Tatsumaki from One Punch. Oh, I think I watched One Punch like season one
I'm not even gonna watch it again
Got green hair
Ash got no titties. That's what i'm talking about. Yeah, give me more anime girls with no titties fad ourselves
I'll cosplay the fuck out of them
I'm glad to revisit raptor again with you. You did a wonderful job. Oh, thank you
I think I did so much better this play through like so so much better than yesterday
It only took a whole slate to to educate myself
Who's the sassy lost champ? Oh, mommy is Tatsumaki
Is Johnny Cosplay win?
Depends
You need to let me give me some more time
Give me some more time because
There's a few things happening behind the scenes right now. And I think uh, you might like the result of them
And feel support of a mummy cosplay. Yeah
Now again the problem with my current outfit is I have my tits so
Okay, uh, there you go. Um
Johnny cosplay the veal or girl now. I'm gonna tell you something that I have backed out of but if you guys want it
I'll let you have it. Okay
I originally was gonna
Now in quotation marks bikini cosplay as my gen mates and I was gonna doodle like their hair on top of me in the pictures
And obviously like, you know, wouldn't show my face or anything like that
um
So I was gonna like, you know get like an orange like micro bikini for me and then ac would be like tooth floss
Um, you know she be would kind of be a bit more. Yeah
I was gonna do that for a donut on reward, but then I backed out of it because I wasn't sure
I don't know we'll discuss it this week
There's a lot of things to discuss if you're a member. I do have a membership stream discussing my personal donut on stuff
Because there was a lot of things where I was like like a bikini cosplay. Yeah, like so far as zero for example, it would be purple
But like I would get one of those like see through veal wrap things to go along with me and then like I see for example
I would buy
Pause so I have bear paws like her
Um, and like big winter boots type thing and tooth floss bikini. Basically
sounds epic to me
um
Yeah, and like emmy would be like orange bikini and then like I put a womb tattoo on that
Like says I love my big brother or something like that
But I didn't want it to be too weird because obviously I need to ask the girls if they're comfortable with that
Bikini cause really more like yes, please and basically I would draw their hair on top of me because obviously I can't even buy wigs for
All of them. It's just for one and done. I'd rather you know, not
Amy's whole body is like smaller than your cake size
Back from the shower what we talking about wise second best girl on stream
uh, because I want to cosplay rebecca later date and
I've already looked over the script for the membership stream and spoiler at mommy talks about
I am
Um, this is a live stream. I'm not pre-recording these streams. They're gonna start freaking believe you the ink will flow
We want bikini you ask him many
um
But yeah, because like I have that
I was also gonna do so. I don't know if you heard about a mole flavor working with a iron mouse and
project melody
I was gonna do like a reward for that as well, but I don't we'll discuss it. It's not pre-recorded stop it
But put it on your eyelashes, right?
Um
So this is have you ever inked to a marshmallow before? Yes, I have. I kind of do it regularly
um
on ironically
Don't know if that's weird. I don't know if it's weird or not, but I do thoroughly enjoy what I get
Um, she who controls the ink controls the universe. We should watch dune. Oh, no, they never completed it dune too was supposed to be
Uh, sorry add the sneezes and then I pick up
And take your meds starting
Well, mate, can you please do an audio sometime where you teach us how to make noise?
I've been taught to be a ninja. Oh, you got ninja pro from black ops one
Uh, how'd that take? Oh
Oh my god, I should
Oh my god, I should do a joy, but you have to like
Do it with me and I'll teach you how to do it, you know
Oh
Oh, now you're giving me some real ideas
As I said, the third editor is now in place so I can start doing stuff that I want to do. You don't want to sing me
Um
Years are turning
Say no more you have me hook line and sinker
Um
Hi, story. Thank you for playing one of my favorite games. Oh, congrats. I played your childhood game
It really makes me happy seeing you enjoy the game. I hope you like infinite. It's my favorite game of all time
Oh, a lot of pressure on internet then
Uh, no, I really enjoyed that. I do apologize for me being in a little shite bag yesterday
But I'm much more confident today. Oh, is ninja a bad thing? No, no, no being the ninja is not a bad thing at all
But if you want to, you know, send me a marshmallow
If you're dead silent
You know
You know, I ask me who says that when my literally my all audios are
And then that's it. That's it. That's the end of the audio
Um
Stronio nasan. Oh, please. I love the big sister is
Dynamic, I don't care. I don't care cancel me. Uh, you can cancel me. It's okay. Um
It's right now
Right now my ink is pretty clear because of all the inking
I couldn't concide you and I don't think I had to worry about getting you pregnant
This stuff needs time to regenerate. Oh my god. Wait, how many times are you doing that? I do
Well, exactly as a marshmallow. It is the q&a that you see in the link below
And you can send me anonymous questions and that's how I read it
Like that's why I know you guys so like our marshmallows just videos are like an audio. Is there anything we can be tech?
You can ask me a question. You can send me an audio. You can send me a video. You can show me a picture
You can ask questions. You can give me feedback on stuff that you didn't like stuff that you did like
The day you cosplay as yourself, I will be completely dry
and
Will there ever be a day we can get the inside scoop? Um, considering what's about to happen
in a couple of months time
Not yet
I should send an audio and paint up of it strongy strong and all
It's more like strongy stroke me off
Thank you. Thank you. I'll be here all week
You'll eat that one like three two days and
Okay
Mommy if you do a bikini stream, I don't know I'll survive. No, not bikini stream
Rebecca technically may be bikini, but you know, I'll be wearing the big jacket that she comes with
Inside scoop on what?
Marshmallow that can't be the rest of it all
Continuous knee slappers. Yeah, you like that
Hi strongy, you should cosplay as my braids are waiting pop up up up. Are you gonna?
Are you gonna consummate our marriage tonight?
Are you gonna consummate me? Go on then show me what a husband can do
Strongly others who the fuck is calling me others I ain't got no kitty
Hi strongy, I tried to censor as much as I can so you can read this on stream
My cuddle pup wife is in heat. Well, then
There's no way I can read this
I want to lead you by your leash to the
Backyard and get you shy and nervous that we might get caught
To start I meant my beloved from no, I can't read I can't read that
That's too much that's too much
That's too much we will make our neighbors hear everything our honeymoon phase is gonna go wild
And
I can't read this
Right
I've stalled enough. I think I think she birds is going live and half an hour
So you're all getting forced to
Do it
Wild card now. I'm curious
Should I
Have no idea how many variants she has at this point
Uh, yeah, I'm gonna go rest. Oh, it's been such a
An endurance stream a whole four hours. Oh that really took the window of my sails. I'm so tired
Okay
The teaser is now getting shy. Well, if you guys if you didn't keep calling me puppy every two seconds, then I wouldn't
Opinions on human sacrifice. Uh, no, not necessary. It won't really work either does it?
Yeah
Wait, someone's gonna make a sheep spreadsheet. I don't know
No, mommy. I miss you already. I mean
Puppy stop it
We love you mommy pop
Thanks for the stream. We'll be getting good rest. Yes, I'm gonna rest and then I'll make something
Um
Stop acting like it. We'll stop calling you
Stop
Okay, I'm gonna go and chill out and then I'll see you shortly
Love you big daddy
She be is gonna be up in 30 minutes. Okay, so go hang out in she be
All right, go support she be cotton bum and all my Jenny
I love you big daddy